chers invités bonjour à tous
je vous souhaite la bienvenue pour cette
audition publique qui va permettre à
l'office de retrouver un sujet qu'il
connaît bien et dont il va aujourd'hui
aborder une dimension spécifique je veux
parler du sujet de la pollution
plastique
en décembre 2020 nos collègues Philippe
Bollot et Angèle Préville on présentait
devant l'office un rapport dont on peut
dire qu'il a fait date nourrit par de
très nombreuses auditions et un travail
extrêmement approfondi
bon j'ai prévu les Philippot sont
devenus en quelque sorte les
spécialistes parlementaires de la
pollution plastique et ils sont
désormais très souvent sollicités pour
présenter les analyses de l'Office que
ce soit dans les médias dans les
enceintes scientifiques ou ailleurs
ils ont d'ailleurs été invités à
participer en début de semaine prochaine
un séminaire franco-américain sur la
recherche scientifique dans ce domaine
comme il l'avait été d'ailleurs l'an
dernier c'est là une marque de
reconnaissance quant au sérieux de nos
travaux nous pouvons donc que nous en
réjouir et vraiment merci à tous les
deux pour votre implication au sein de
l'office
en décembre 2020 donc je le disais le
rapport de l'Office préconisé la
négociation d'un traité mondial en vue
de réduire la pollution plastique en
mars 2022 l'Assemblée des Nations Unies
pour l'Environnement réunis dans le
cadre du Programme des Nations Unies
pour Environnement a adopter une
résolution prévoyant que serait élaboré
un instrument international
juridiquement contraignant pour mettre
fin à la pollution plastique 5 réunions
du Comité international de négociation
son programmées d'ici fin 2024 et la
France accueille la deuxième réunion à
la fin du mois c'est la raison pour
laquelle l'Office a décidé d'organiser
une audition publique sur les enjeux
scientifiques liés à ce projet de traité
international une première table ronde
traitera des raisons scientifiques qui
poussent à l'élaboration de ce traité
je laisserai mes collègues présentés
l'ensemble des intervenants et une
seconde s'intéressera aux enjeux
scientifiques des propositions en
discussion
bien ben écoutez sans plus tarder je
laisse la parole à Angers Preville pour
lancer la première table ronde la
Mercedes vous avez la parole merci merci
monsieur le Président donc merci d'ores
et déjà tout nous intervenants et pour
aller très vite je vais présenter les
les intervenants de la première table
ronde vous avez
10 minutes pour un propos liminaire afin
que nous puissions avoir le temps après
d'échange donc notre première
intervenant est Monsieur Andrès del
Castillo avocat senior au centre pour le
droit international de l'environnement
qui va évoquer la pollution plastique
sous l'angle du dépassement des limites
planétaires en ce qui concerne les
polluants chimiques environnementaux
dont font partie les plastiques je
rappelle qu'en 2009 paraissait une étude
scientifique qui identifiait 9 limites
planétaires à ne pas dépasser pour que
l'humanité continue à vivre dans un
écosystème sûr
il s'agit de la pollution atmosphérique
par aérosol la perturbation du cycle de
l'eau de l'eau douce l'appauvrissement
de la couche d'ozone la signification
des océans le réchauffement climatique
bien sûr le changement d'affectation des
sols les flux biochimiques l'érosion de
la biodiversité et la pollution par des
substances nouvelles parmi les trois
limites planétaires dépassées figurent
la pollution par des substances
nouvelles notamment en raison de
l'explosion de la production des
plastiques monsieur del Castillo vous
avez la parole
merci Madame
prévu sénatrice
Monsieur Henri député et président de
l'office monsieur longer sénateur
président première vue s'est passé dans
de l'office et collègue je suis
reconnaissant de pouvoir me rendre à
Paris pour cette séance
pertinent et à la fois nécessaire
comment une véritable prélude à la
Réunion qui est Paris
accueillira dans presque deux à trois
semaines donc plus de 2003
experts vont se réunir de plus de 163
pays pour discuter ce qui sera
approchant instrument juridiquement
contraignante
donc
c'est passé là
bon
je pense que
oui
mon intervention et notamment ça sera
tout d'abord on peut sans une première
idée de qu'est-ce qu'on parle lorsqu'on
parle des pollutions plastiques parce
que il y a une évolution du terme de ce
qu'on comprend par pollution plastique
en commençant par lycée que c'est une
accumulation des débris
plastique dans l'environnement physique
plus la biota mais on est maintenant
dans un stade dont la même définition il
apportait même de qu'est-ce qui pourra
être couvert par un instrument et
peut-être défini avec ce qu'on comprend
par la pollution plastique déjà il y a
deux rapports phares présentés par là
au-dessus de en 2022 que ont déjà
démontré il donnait une définition qui
pourrait être la définition
décidé à pareil pour travailler
il sait qu'est-ce qu'on comprend pas
plastique je me permets de lire de
manière générale toutes les émissions et
tous les risques résultant de la
production de la utilisation et de la
gestion des déchets et des fuites des
matières plastiques il faut bien
souligner ici que l'État émission puis
peut-être est plus
vu aussi comme les rejets il essaies
nous comprenons les émissions plutôt sur
l'atmosphère atmosphérique et sur l'air
des des particules des gaz et des gaz
effets de serre puis les rejets quand
lorsqu'on parle de l'écosystème
aquatique plus le sol et là quand on
parle des fuites aussi il faut voir que
les fuites juridiquement c'est quelque
chose
que limite un peu la définition et on
voit que parler des rejets c'est plus
convenable et prochain
donc
pour comprendre
la pollution plastique il faut la mettre
en perspective avec ce que madame
privilat a bien dit sur les 9 processus
biophysiques cargoût la stabilité il la
résilience du système terrestre
ou c'est connu comme limite planétaire
on est en train de passer
à l'anthropocène donc une période
actuelle des temps géologiques
et où les activités humaines ont une
forte répercussion sur les écosystèmes
de la planète la bienfaits
donc déjà il y a une évolution de cette
cadre qui était posée sur la table en
2009 on descend on avait déjà
transgresse c'est trois limites
planétaires à 2022 on part déjà qu'on a
les données pour constater que on a
transgresser 6 de 9 dans l'année
dernière
on a eu un
nouvel sur ce qu'on appelle la
contamination par des produits chimiques
qui ont compris maintenant par les
nouvelles Saintes en disant que cette
dimension était transgressée il son
évolution d'un document sorti en 2018
qui dit si on est un risque d'être
limite planétaire à dire on a la
traversée l'année dernière c'est c'est
un peu les constats que que je viens à
partager avec vous et pourquoi on la
tracer qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire pour
essayer de résoudre cette problématique
est-ce que c'est possible d'aller en
arrière à lecène en nouveau on sait que
selon ces documents c'est plus possible
mais c'est possible de d'un peu arrêter
les dommages et les qui pourront être
causés donc
qu'est-ce qu'on considère peut-être
prochaine des positif
par de nouvelles syndiqués on parle de
nouvelles substances de nouvelles formes
des substances existants ils forment des
vies modifiées on parle des produits
chimiques
idiotes des nouveaux types de matériaux
odeur organismes manufacturés inconnues
auparavant du système terrestre et on
parle des éléments naturels par exemple
des méthodes et
mobiliser par les activités
entre anthropiques il a
il y a un graphique fait par un des
scientifiques dans un document que en
train de dépasser tous les tous les
étapes des rémission des pères qui ont
l'appelle la tête de la Méduse mettant
les 8 planétaires tout autour et au
centre les plastiques il interaction
entre les plastiques il commande
finalement les plastiques exacer les
autres limites planétaires donc
on n'aura pas le temps de
voir
de tous les intersections mais je vais
me centrer surtout sur la partie
correspondant au changement climatique
prochain et
si on prend l'exemple du changement
climatique et vous voyez dans un
graphique c'est que un coton gablégation
marquez mes amis l'ampleur de notre
solitude
en regardant les graphiques qui étaient
présentés dans les 6e rapport de
valuation du groupe d'experts
sur l'évolution du climat ça montre les
changements de température mondiales et
on ne s'est pas remis en terre pensée en
haute graphie fait par la
OCDE et montrant le mutation la
perspective qui va tripler la production
annuelle des plastiques on est à une
production annuelle de 400 millions de
tonnes par année et on va passer d'ici à
60 à
1,10 milliard de tonnes des productions
par année si on n'arrive pas à gérer ses
propres produits maintenant pouvez-vous
vous séminiser dans un monde plus chaud
puis avec plus d'un milliards de
production de plastique par année et de
notre contrée on ne s'imagine pas donc
il faut agir il sait ça que les Nations
Unies il est ensemble d'État ont fait
l'année dernière en donnant un pas en
décembre plastique d'une façon
holistique pas seulement se concentrer
sur les détritus sur les sous les
déchets plastiques mais sur toute son
cycle de vie
donc un prochain
il a continué sur les questions du
changement climatique
on sait
que les plastiques en effet sur les
climat il menace la possibilité de
invisager en monde en dessous des 1,5
degrés Celsius pourquoi un rapport qu'on
a fait dans notre centre
dit que d'ici à 2050 les émissions des
gars de gaz à effet de serre provenant
du plastique ou de toutes les cycles de
vie du plastique pour en attendre plus
de 56 gigatonnes ce qui représente des
10 on parle maintenant déjà de 13% de
l'ensemble de budget carbone restants et
il y a certains études qui dit que pour
s'approcher au budget carbone de
l'entreprise l'industrie du plastique en
général au lieu de maintenir des 4% par
année la production on devrait
rétrograder et diminuer la demande des
matières plastiques des trois portions
par année
et pour arriver à couper on a à la
moitié d'ici à 2050 y rester dans dans
le budget carbone
attribué à cette à toute l'industrie du
plastique
et là je suis navré c'est tellement
petit mais vous serez la question de
revoir un peu toutes ce qui concerne les
cycles de vie des plastiques les
différents états parce qu'on part des
plastiques à différents
matières premières utilisées pour les
plastiques on part des plastiques leur
compare des précautions plastiques et il
a une butane il est chimiques basiques
sont utilisés pour la préparation des
des monomères puis polymères plus les
additifs que sont nécessaires et on part
déplacer lorsque on part des racines ou
des matières plastiques elles-mêmes là
on connaît les 7 les pets on connaît les
numéros 2
puis les produits plastiques eux-mêmes
donc il faut bien faire la différence
lorsqu'on part de plastique entre
matières plastiques c'est abstriment et
les produits plastiques puis les déchets
plastiques qui sont un peu plus sympa du
cycle de vie
donc à droite il s'est un peu impossible
de voir pour vous déjà les Nations Unies
a récolté et qu'est-ce qu'on dit
67 pays au groupe des pays pour ce qui
devrait contenir les prochains
international mais ça fera fait plutôt
des douzième panel de cette de cette
journée et le prochain
et un peu pour finir il y a un rapport
qui vient de sortir la semaine dernière
et on est au milieu presque à la fin de
la négociation de la Conférence des
Parties pour les conventions de balles
rotterdamnés
donc
il y a un rapport que c'était fait par
rapport au plastique pas dans la
dimension climat mais cette fois dans la
dimension chimie qui démontre qui a plus
de 13000
produits chimiques qui sont utilisés
pour la production des plastiques
IDC 13000 on n'a pas donné presque la
moitié de 6000 mais c'est qu'on est à
donner c'est presque 7000 on peut dire
que la moitié que presque
3200 produits chimiques sont des
substances de préoccupations selon les
scientifiques on sait qu'un niveau
mondial si on prend ensemble la
conversion des Mina Mata les protocoles
de Montréal puis la conversion des
Stockholm
il y a que 128 produits qui sont régulés
de cette 3200 que ceux qui sont des
produits chimie des hautes
préoccupations quand vous voyez ça
peut-être on peut vous donner une bonne
nouvelle maintenant on parle pas des 128
mais des30 parce que la semaine dernière
la conversion des Stockholm a décidé de
prendre considération de produits
chimiques M+ qui sont utilisés comme
retard dans des flammes puis comme
filtre UV c'est le UV 328 que c'est une
vraie nouvelle parce que ça permet un
peu de voir que les critères pour les
polluants organiques persistants et au
les véhicules qui fait que les
polluences c'est sont partout dans la
planète sont aussi et les plastiques
eux-mêmes parce que ça peut être ici
mais d'ici à quelques semaines ça peut
se retrouver dans différents coins de la
planète donc
mais si on continue avec cette approche
en en prenant deux trois quatre cinq ans
à évaluer à classer les différents
substances va finir d'ici je ne suis pas
qu'on a pas fait les calculs mais pour
les traiter le plastique ça sera
important de voir comment la
simplification chimie il sait très gros
prénom et étudier comme on déjà l'Union
européenne les faits commence à les
faire avec les pie face pour plus de
10000 substances que par appartient à la
famille de pie face pour BPA qui l'a
fait avec plus d'essence
56 substances ça permet un peu d'aller
plus loin de ce que les marchés fait
parce qu'on sait qu'il y a plus de 350
000 produits chimiques on était produit
et que 2000 sont des polymères donc en
barre des chiffres très soft il faut un
peu l'aide de droit et de la volonté
politique pour arriver à combler
ça on ne part pas d'éliminer les
plastiques mais on part des contrôler
une substance qui est hors contrôle
aujourd'hui dernière diapositive s'il
vous plaît donc là il y a les dossiers
rapports qui étaient sortis qui ont par
des
10 groupes des Soustons chimiques donc
il faudra
s'attaquer au niveau du traité pour voir
comment contrôler ce genre de substances
là je vais pas les lire mais j'ai déjà
mentionné les bisphénols les pie face
les filtres UV et il est biocide
prochain
il a qu'est-ce que la science nous dit
certains scientifiques nous dit deux
choses supplément plafonder la
production des plastiques vierges c'est
une des options sinon la première option
qui est qui est documenté par l'ONU qui
sera mis sur la table lors de la
discussion à Paris
il parlait de la simplification chimique
donc finalement c'est limitant les
nombres des substances qui sont mis qui
sont mélangés ils sont sur le marché sur
une logique des non datanes s'il y a pas
de données il y a pas de marché pour
introduire des systèmes chimiques qui en
regroupant l'évaluation et le contrôle
de produits chimiques est utilisé dans
les matières plastiques et avec ça j'ai
fini mon intervention merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup nous allons passer
maintenant deuxième intervenant Monsieur
Hervé corvelec professeur à l'Université
de lutte en Suède la pollution plastique
résulte de l'extraordinaire succès
rencontré par le plastique dans tous nos
usages pour lutter efficacement contre
cette pollution nous ne pouvons pas nous
contenter d'essayer d'améliorer la
gestion de la fin de vie des plastiques
il nous faut réduire drastiquement sa
production et par conséquent notre
consommation pour cela il est
indispensable de comprendre les ressorts
économiques qui nous poussent à
consommer toujours plus de plastique et
à s'intéresser aux
usages c'est le sujet de l'intervention
de Monsieur corvelec à qui je laisse la
parole merci
je vous remercie
merci beaucoup pour votre invitation
et je vais essayer donc de cadrer
pourquoi tant de déchets plastiques
diapositive merci
entendez-vous
oui très bien
est-ce que vous pouvez passer la
prochaine diapositive s'il vous plaît
merci on connaît on sait exactement où
va le plastique à peu près 40% dans les
emballages à peu près 20% dans la
construction à partir de ça on peut
essayer de se poser la question que
faire à ces choses la prochaine
diapositive s'il vous plaît
parce qu'il y a un paradoxe à la
consommation plastique les plastiques
sont omniprésents pourtant ils sont
rarement activement choisis par le
consommateur c'est à dire que le
plastique est un accompagnateur discret
diapositive s'il vous plaît
le plastique suit par exemple si vous
achetez un concombre mensuel ou j'habite
si ce concombre est par exemple
écologique ce qui est paradoxal et ben
il se rend il sera emballé
individuellement dans du plastique de la
même manière si vous utilisez une
automobile et bien vous utiliserez
énormément de plastique par exemple
comme cette cette photo de plastique
omium des montres que ce soit les
pare-chocs que ça soit les protections
cette fois de latérale au-dessus etc le
plastique est omniprésent d'ailleurs la
part des plastiques est passé à 30% du
poids du véhicule contre 17% 2011 donc
c'est augmentation de la présence du
plastique et finalement somme toute
assez récente s'il vous plaît moi j'aime
diapo il y a quelques exceptions
quelques exceptions par exemple on peut
effectivement choisir des jouets en bois
plutôt géoplastiques on peut choisir par
exemple des fenêtres en PVC plutôt que
des fenêtres en aluminium ou par exemple
certains produits par exemple comme des
lavettes on peut choisir des lavettes en
tissu par contre bon comme nous
connaissant pas ce produit
particulièrement je soupçonne par contre
le produit des lavés en tissu d'être
emballé dans du plastique mais ça ce
n'est qu'un des paradoxes de plus
diapositive s'il vous plaît
donc à part à part ces exceptions qui
sont à le plastique suit et là je vais
vous simplement commenter une photo ça
c'est un œuf qui a un œuf qui a été
Pâques qui a été offert à mon épouse
cette année du 2 mars qui s'appelle
Antoine Berg les petits œufs en
participant étaient à emballés dans un
des petits sacs en plastique vous voyez
sur le dessus de l'image les gros yeux
en participant est en pleine dans un
autre sac en plastique
lesquels étaient tous les deux placés
dans le sac en tissu à gauche le tag en
tissu noir lequel ça en tissu et plein
d'élastic de m'attirer élastique qui
sont eux-mêmes des plastiques et le sac
en tissu noir était placé à son tour
dans l'oeuf que vous voyez en couleur en
couleur dorée qui était installe neuf en
plastique qui était donc embalège sur
pas et sur cette emballage là était
attaché une petite étiquette avec donc
la marque le nom du producteur par un
petit fil que vous voyez au dessus de
l'oeuf de la du demi oeuf à droite qui
est tout lui-même en plastique
bon je pense que si vous venez d'après
ça je pense que cette image illustre
quand même assez bien que la présence du
plastique dans les produits est un choix
de designer de producteur et de
distributeurs surtout que cette offre là
a du très beau gosse être en plus comme
on dit enrobé par du plastique
supplémentaire lors de la distribution
donc en ce sens ce qui est intéressant
c'est que pour reprendre un petit peu
les termes de Michel Serres c'est un
parasite c'est-à-dire le plastique les
chevilles se nourrit de la présence des
autres produits en le permettant à ces
autres produits de fonctionner prochaine
diapos s'il vous plaît merci c'est un
pour ça que j'appellerai un passeur de
qualité prochainement s'il vous plaît ça
à partir de qualité et là quand je parle
de patients de qualité je me réfère à la
notion d'économie des qualités de Michel
Callon qui explique que en fait les
produits sont qualifiés représentent une
certaine nombre de qualités que c'est
pour ça qu'en fait ils sont sur le
marché et donc les qualités du plastique
et bien c'est d'agir par exemple comme
produit barrière c'est par exemple la
légèreté de la commodité au sens de
l'anglais comme vignettes c'est donc la
possibilité pour le plastique de
permettre à ces produits là que par
exemple que ce soit l'automobile que ça
soit que ça soit un œuf de Pâques que ça
soit du chocolat que ça soit
un concombre de passer de passer ces
produits de passer ses qualités
tronçonneuse prochaine diapos s'il vous
plaît par exemple le plastique permet de
passer la qualité d'abondance par
exemple là une la photo à gauche
démontre par exemple une étagère vous
voyez cette omniprésent des emballages
plastiques ou chaque produit représenté
plusieurs fois pour pouvoir augmenter la
durée de vie la distribution ayant
horreur du vide sur les étagères on
représente on emballage on emballe
chaque produit plastique chaque produit
végétal dans du plastique pour produire
cette impression d'abondance ou de
commodité par exemple
d'individualisation des choix qui fait
que au lieu d'avoir un seul produit
offert et bien on va voir un produit
offert dans un dans une FLA dans un goût
rouge un goût bleu un goût orange etc
donc on a toutes ces qualités là mais il
y a d'autres qualités par exemple le
plastique permet de transfert permettre
de passer la qualité de rapidité et on
sait combien la rapidité est essentielle
à la mod ernité et ça c'est ça depuis
Paul virio par exemple l'omniprésence de
la consommation qu'on connaît quand même
depuis très longtemps ou de l'hyperm
mobilité des matériaux des produits et
des gens le plastique permettent en
permanence de passer ces choses là de
passer ses qualités prochaine photo s'il
vous plaît
donc la mobilité est sécurité sont parmi
les qualités essentielles de consommer
en mouvement de se protéger on se
protège par exemple avec un casque mais
on ne se protège pas de la même manière
des risques plastiques bien mis en avant
par le précédent intervenant prochaine
photo s'il vous plaît
parmi ces qualités là il y a une qualité
qui est essentielle chez le plastique
c'est ce que j'appellerai la jetabilité
si le plastique est aussi intéressant
c'est parce qu'il est jetable c'est
parce qu'on peut le jeter si l'idée
d'avoir de vendre si on peut arriver à
vendre 1,3 milliards de bouteilles d'eau
chaque jour un amas de qui montrait
jusqu'à la moitié elle Tour Eiffel c'est
parce qu'on peut jeter après l'usage
cette cette bouteille la jetabilité est
une une condition et c'est intéressant
parce que cette présence du plastique
comme jetable et déjà à l'origine du
plastique lorsque les archéologistes de
les décharges par exemple Radji et
Murphy ont creusé selon la technique de
l'archéologie les décharges publics aux
États-Unis les produits produits non
plus précis qu'ils ont découvert étaient
des cols plastiques en défaut colle en
celluloïde c'est des choses qui étaient
faites déjà pour être jetés et on a une
expression qui à mon avis est très
intéressante par l'anthropologue
australienne Hawkins c'est mate to be
wasted ce sont des choses qui sont
produites qui sont dessinés qui ont le
destin de pouvoir devenir un déchet
c'est à dire qu'elles sont elles sont
pour être jeté
et à ce sens là je voudrais la prochaine
diapos s'il vous plaît le plastique
participe très très largement à ce qu'on
appellerait la normalité du déchet c'est
bien parce qu'on a cette jetabilité qui
est
omniprésente dans l'usage du plastique
et qui fait partie par exemple même de
l'offre parce que lorsqu'on achète une
bouteille d'eau en plastique on achète
tout autant la mobilité la possibilité
de se déplacer la possibilité d'emmener
l'eau avec soi qui est rendue possible
par la bouteille plastique que l'eau et
c'est assez paradoxal parce qu'on achète
pas le plastique on achète l'eau mais le
plastique est en fait ce qui permet de
consommer l'eau selon les politiques de
gestion souvent les stratégies des
entreprises et cette politique de
gestion de gestion des entre gestion des
entreprises et de distribution de l'eau
et entièrement basé sur le fait qu'il
est normal il est considéré comme
légitime à la fin de l'usage de jeter
cette bouteille donc de la disponibilité
la prochaine fois s'il vous plaît
et dans cette normalisation du déchet le
recyclage joue un rôle clé par exemple
si on prend une des grandes entreprises
des grands par exemple le lobby européen
comme plastique Europe en plastique
Europe est un supporter très actif du
recyclage de plastique par exemple ils
insistent toujours sur le potentiel
l'importance de développement par
exemple le recyclage chimique qui
permettra de contourner un des grands
problèmes des recyclages mécaniques du
plastique en particulier les additifs et
considérer en que ceux le recyclage est
un élément clé du passage à l'économie
circulaire elle-même faisant partie de
la de la stratégie verte de l'Union
européenne c'est très intéressant c'est
un petit peu comme à l'époque du
Moyen-Âge lorsque les indulgences
permettaient de
s'affranchir de la responsabilité donc
de ses péchés
et bien le recyclage permet de sept de
ne pas poser la question de pourquoi le
déchets plastiques le recyclage permet
de ne pas se poser la question de
pourrait-on faire autrement pourtant au
contraire ça permet de maintenir
l'illusion qu'il est possible de
contrôler le déchet voire d'en faire une
ressource et ça participe à les
limitations de la responsabilité des
producteurs des distributeurs et des
consommateurs en matière de production
du déchet le déchet considéré comme
normal et ce sens-là le recyclage joue
un rôle de légitimation très important
et ce prochain diapos s'il vous plaît ce
alors même qu'il y a un problème
fondamental dans le recyclage du
plastique et dans d'une manière générale
le traitement du plastique au niveau du
déchet c'est que toutes les qualités qui
font du plastique quelque chose est très
intéressant pour la production s'inverse
plus ou moins lorsqu'on parle de de
recyclage et du traitement de déchets
c'est à dire que lorsque le plastique
par exemple qui est léger sa légèreté
combiné à son faible coût rend la
collecte du plastique peut rentable
parce que ce qui va tirer les coups de
la collecte ça sera le kilomètre et
l'heure alors que ce qui va tirer les
revenus de cette collecte sera le poids
et la valeur au kilo le prix au kilo et
donc lorsqu'on aura des plastiques qui
prennent beaucoup de volume et qui sont
légers et qui sont pas chers et bien il
est très très difficile pour les
entreprises de collecte de déchets de
pouvoir financer leur collecte des
déchets en revendant les produits donc
là il y a même un problème assez
fondamental il y a un un petit exemple
fait que le plastique est en très
malléable on va le retrouver partout
même à l'intérieur des choses on va le
trouver comme par exemple enrobant du
métal ou enrobant du vert ce qui va
permettre s'il ne va pas forcément
permettre de le recycler ou de le
retraiter ce qui pose des problèmes de
déchets difficiles à traiter de la même
manière la résistance du plastique par
exemple à l'eau au base aux acides aux
ultraviolets entraîne une durabilité qui
fait que il est très très difficile de
pouvoir le traiter et qu'on le retrouve
dans la nature pendant très longtemps
donc il y a une espèce d'un certain
version du plastique des qualités du
plastique lorsqu'il devient un déchet
quitte à mettre en perspective par
rapport à la légitimité justement de
jeter du plastique
et quelque part le déchet nous renvoie
avec une espèce de violence lent de
violence lente à la confiance que nous
apportons au plastique pour notre
bien-être parce qu'on a cette confiance
permanente que nous accordons au
plastique justement avec la jetabilité
et cette confiance nous revient
dans son contraire
lorsque c'est le plastique devient des
chefs prochaine s'il vous plaît et là il
y a un cas d'urgence c'est la cigarette
électronique à usage usine unique parce
que la cigarette outre d'être un défi à
la santé à la santé publique en
particulier chez les jeunes génère un
déchet plastique très très déchets
plastique des chaînes métal d'échelle
électroniques très très difficile à
gérer et là on a un excellent exemple de
la question de la légitimité de mise sur
leur marché de quelque chose qui génère
du déchet systématiquement là on a la
question à se poser comment peut-on
accorder une autorisation de mise sur le
marché d'un produit qui va générer du
déchet en particulier du déchet
plastique qui ne sera pas facilement
traitable voire même carrément un
traitable acceptez de mettre sur le
marché des produits tels que la
cigarette électronique à usage unique
c'est accepter que le traitement du
déchet sera toujours à la traîne par
rapport à la mise sur le marché de
produits
et encore une photo s'il vous plaît
diapos s'il vous plaît et donc ce qui
est intéressant c'est que le déchet
plastique et là je suis le raisonnement
d'Amanda boite caisse qui est une
professeur d'art dans son livre
classique capitalisme que le déchet
plastique est une condition de
possibilité du système économique
contemporain que ça soit pour la
mobilité la gestion du risque
l'adaptabilité ou la globalisation il
n'y a aucun trait du système économique
contemporain qui soit pas dépendant d'un
usage intensif du plastique ce qui
explique très bien pourquoi l'usage
intensif du plastique se retrouve
partout avec les conséquences démontré
par le président intervenant et donc
l'apparition a plus ou moins interne de
plus de déchets plastiques cette
croissance parce que il est la présence
du déchet plastique est consubstantiel à
au développement de la d'activité
économique en général et le déchet
plastique nous renvoie en permanence ou
non pensées de la production de la
distribution de la consommation pour
tout ce qui est après le premier usage
ce n'est pas pensé c'est-à-dire que il y
a cette idée que quelque part les
personnes et la personne suivante va
pouvoir s'occuper du déchet le déchet va
quelque part pour être traité neutralisé
contrôler mais
ce n'est pas le cas et c'est exactement
le défi de l'anthropocène et le défi par
exemple de la pollution plastique dans
les mers ou dans les montagnes ou dans
l'air que on sait très bien aujourd'hui
qu'on ne va pas arriver à gérer ce
plastique si on continue à en générer la
production à ce rythme là mais quelque
part cette espèce de non pensée de la
production distribution à consommation
pour le déchet nous renvoie à notre
appétence pour ce qui est rapide c'est
léger c'est coloré c'est bon marché
c'est pratique et une illusion du sans
souci et que le déchet plastique est
intimement lié à nos préférences à nos
pratiques à la production et que si on
veut traiter le déchet plastique mais il
va falloir détricoter le maillage très
serré que l'industrie du plastique a
fait de nos sociétés je vous remercie de
votre attention
merci beaucoup pour cette intervention
nous allons maintenant passer à notre
troisième intervenant qui est Monsieur
Gérone sonke directeur de recherche au
CNRS les microplastiques ont envahi tous
les compartiments environnementaux on
les retrouve dans les océans dans les
fleuves dans les sols mais également
dans les airs au sommet des montagnes
sur les glaces et même dans les fausses
marines les plus profondes comment
modifier ces flux de plastique pour
endresser un bilan global à l'échelle
planétaire c'est à cette tâche que c'est
atelier votre équipe pour établir le
premier modèle compréhensif du cycle de
vie des plastiques et de microplastiques
je vous laisse la parole pour 10 minutes
pour expliquer votre modèle et les
résultats obtenus merci d'avance
merci Madame c'est une actrice vous
m'entendez bien
j'entends très bien
bonjour à toutes et à tous je vais donc
faire aujourd'hui un point sur le cycle
de vie du plastique et les
microplastiques vraiment à l'arche du
ciel échelle de la planète avancer s'il
vous plaît
[Musique]
donc les chiffres voici les statistiques
de production des plastiques depuis les
années 50 donc une croissance en continu
pour aujourd'hui un chiffre des 450
millions de tonnes par an donc une tonne
représente le poids d'une petite voiture
donc l'équivalent des 450 millions de
voitures en poids de plastique produit
chaque année se faire à base de pétrole
si on regarde la production du pétrole
on divise les deux on s'est réalise que
12% du pétrole chaque année est converti
en polymère majoritairement pour les
emballages à usage unique
prochaine diapo
donc depuis les années 50 une totalité
de 8300 millions de tonnes de plastique
ont été produits ça suffit pour tapisser
la France entière avec 50 cm de polymère
ou encore comme le couple de cristaux
tristement prévu peut-être une couche de
8 mm sur toute la terre prochaine il y a
pas
donc ici à gauche c'est à nouveau les
8300 millions de tonnes de plastique
produit depuis tout les temps on estime
aujourd'hui que 30% mais ce plastique
est toujours en utilisation dans les
pare-chocs de voitures les coques de nos
ordinateurs et téléphones par exemple
2/3 de ses plastiques ont été laissés à
usage unique et de celle du tiers la
moitié se trouve en décharge parfois à
ciel ouvert parfois manager correctement
l'autre moitié est rejeté directement
dans l'environnement une petite
pourcentage 10% et incinérer aujourd'hui
pour générer du CO2 c'est pas bon non
plus et environ 8% est recyclé mais dans
ce diagramme vous voyez bien que après
recyclage un ou deux fois ça rejoint ça
rejoint l'incinérateur la décharge ou
rjt dans l'environnement donc quand
est-il à la dispersion de toutes ces
plastiques jetés dans l'environnement ou
présent dans les décharges prochain
diapo
donc je vous inviter à réfléchir avec
moi à un cycle de plastique à l'échelle
de la planète une dispersion qui va de
compartiment à compartiment un peu comme
ce cycle de l'eau que vous connaissez
bien avec précipitation
évaporation depuis etc avec plein de
chiffres prochain diapos
donc voici un concept du cycle du
plastique à l'échelle de la planète on
va distinguer dans ce cycle et les
macropastiques qui sont plus larges que
5 mm les bouteilles les plus grands
objets mais aussi les microplastiques de
un micromètre à 5 mm il y a les
microplastiques primaires qui sont
produits pour être utilisés tel quel
dans les produits cosmétiques dans la
peinture par exemple donc à droite dans
la boîte verte on va trouver toutes les
plastiques en utilisation et elles sont
rejetées vers la gauche il y a les
flèches vers les déchets les décharges
et le milieu urbain industriels laissant
l'agricoles qui reçoivent les
microplastiques qui chutent des bouts de
station d'épuration toutes les textiles
qui sont lavés toutes ces fibres
terminent finalement dans les boues et
les sols agricoles et ensuite les
flèches rouges les fleuves qui lentement
vont amener disperser ces plastiques et
microplastiques vers le milieu marin
d'avoir la surface de l'océan ensuite
c'est plastique qui flottent pour le
moment elles vont sédimenter
pénétrer dans l'océan profond et vont se
retrouver finalement dans les sédiments
côtiers ou être déposés sur les plages
on sait aujourd'hui également qu'il y a
un cycle atmosphérique qui a l'abrasion
des pneus par exemple
et tout ce qui est émis également par
l'océan vers la concerne va se reposer
plus loin sur l'océan ou sur les sols
naturels les glaciers toutes les milieux
terrestres précis donc l'enjeu ces
dernières années a été de mettre des
chiffres sur les quantités de plastique
dans ces compartiments et sur les flux
sur toute la flèches que vous voyez
prochain
donc j'ai rajouté encore quelques
flèches pour la fragmentation des
macroplastics en microplastiques dans
ces compartiments à la fois terrestres
marins ou sur les plages
donc pour mettre des chiffres dessus on
a besoin d'observation avec nos équipes
à l'observatoire midi-pyréné on a
surtout travaillé sur l'atmosphère sans
rentrer dans des détails on a regardé la
neige au-dessus les Pyrénées l'air en
haute altitude sur le pic du Midi ou
encore la brume marine sur la façade
atlantique prochain
d'autres collègues ont exploré l'océan
profond on travaille depuis longtemps à
la surface mais les profond c'était
assez inconnu et que les études des cinq
dernières années illuminent les
quantités de plastique présentes dans
cet océan profond à droite une figure
avec les teneurs les concentrations à
microplastiques jusqu'à 10 mm de
profondeur dans la fosse des Mariannes
et on en trouve partout prochain
et donc ce type d'études des centaines
d'études permettent donc aujourd'hui
d'affiner et de comprendre la dispersion
des plastiques et microplastiques vers
les milieux prestines le chiffre qu'on
connaissait bien déjà depuis 10 ans
c'est la quantité qui flotte à la
surface de l'océan ici en 0,3 millions
de tonnes c'est une petite chiffre
finalement quand on se rend compte avec
les nouveaux chiffres que dans l'océan
profond se retrouvent autour des 82
millions de tonnes 300 fois plus qu'à la
surface également dans les sédiments
côtés ont été déposés déjà plus de 100
millions de tonnes de plastique
on découvre aussi que les émissions
marines étaient restres ont alimenté les
sommes naturels pourris retrouver 28
millions de tonnes qui finalement avec
la pluie et les flèches rouges vont
rejoindre l'océan dans une sorte de
boucle infernale de microplastiques
jusqu'à ce qu'elle dépose dans les
sédiments marins
on savait déjà je l'avais dit au début
un peu plus de 8000 millions de tonnes
ont été produits sont aujourd'hui
présents dans le milieu terrestre
prochain diapo et donc si on fait le
bilan de ce bilan il y a des chiffres en
bas de ce diapo on observe 97% des
plastiques produits se retrouvent
toujours en milieu terrestre dans les
décharges dans la nature ou en
utilisation et seulement 3% des
plastiques et microplastiques ont été
mobilisés vers le milieu marin ou encore
les sols naturels
prochain diapo nous avons ensuite
traduit ce premier bilan en modèle
numérique mathématique pour regarder les
échelles de temps
impliqués dans la dispersion et
fragmentation des microplastiques dans
ces écosystèmes
et donc on est obligé dans ce dans ce
modèle de simplifier on a supposé une
taux de fragmentation de 3% par an donc
une bouteille au cours de 100 ans disons
valent lentement fragmenté en
microplastiques donc vous avez un
exemple de simulation de modèles ici
avec sur X
le temps de l'anémie 1950 vers l'an 2000
2040 on simule un scénario d'arrêt de
production 2040 des plastiques sans
doute irraisonnable mais juste pour vous
donner une idée de cette échelle de
temps et après on simule jusqu'à l'an
3000 le prochain millénaire
et donc vous voyez le la croissance de
ce réservoir en bleu les déchets
plastiques terrestre jusqu'à 2040 on
arrête de produire ensuite il y a des
croissances à cause de cette
fragmentation à microplastie et donc on
va retrouver un pic en verre des déchets
de microplastiques un siècle après qui à
son tour va mobiliser disperser vers
l'océan et via lammaire vers les sols
naturels en parallèle les prochains
siècles vous allez voir une croissance
de présence de microplastiques dans le
milieu marin l'océan profond ici et dans
les sols naturels et donc cette
simulation finalement il faut le
prolonger jusqu'à 20 000 ans pour pour
que toutes les microplastiques
finalement
[Musique]
se dépose dans les sédiments marins et
ce stabiliser en dehors d'un vécu system
de surface donc cette échelle de temps à
cause de cette fragmentation
très long et donc le risque se pose
réellement que pendant des millénaires
nous devrons faire face à des plastiques
qu'on a déjà pollué aujourd'hui ça c'est
quand on arrête de produire en 2040 pour
changer diapo et c'est le dernier donc
quelques chiffres à retenir 12% du
pétrole est converti chaque année et
polymères c'est vraiment une quantité
extraordinaire et ça risque d'accroître
encore
finalement 3% des plastiques ont donc
été mobilisés du milieu de terrestre
vers le milieu marin et les sons de
Christine la majorité des plastiques se
trouvent toujours en milieu terrestre
à cause de cette fragmentation lente ça
peut aggraver leur impact pendant les
millénaires et il est clair qu'en fin de
limiter ces dispersion et fragmentations
il faut absolument limiter la production
revenir à zéro c'est probablement
irréaliste mais on peut énormément
limiter il faut améliorer la gestion des
déchets dans les pays du Sud mais aussi
chez nous et probablement il faut
assainir les déchets déjà présents dans
le milieu terrestre afin que ça ne se
disperse pas pendant des millénaires
pour causer toute une tas de problèmes
toxiques merci pour votre attention
merci beaucoup pour votre présentation
et nous allons passer à notre quatrième
intervenant Monsieur Xavier cousin
chercheur à l'inrae affecté à l'unité
mixte de recherche marbec pour Marine
bio
diversity exploitation
les images choc de mammifères marins
étranglés par un engin de pêche ont
révélé au grand public l'impact de la
pollution plastique sur la faune marine
pour autant ces images ne sont que la
partie visible de l'iceberg de la
pollution plastique qui touche toute la
chaîne trophique c'est ce que va nous
expliquer monsieur cousin à qui je
laisse la parole merci d'avance
merci madame la sénatrice si bonjour à
tous si je peux avoir les diapos
oui
donc effectivement les images de
d'animaux marins prisonniers ou
asphyxier par les déchets plastiques on
fait le tour du monde ça a offert une
très grande visibilité à la
problématique des déchets dans le milieu
marin on a encore des images là sous les
yeux
se passent de commentaires
et c'est une problématique qui reste une
réalité puisque lors des de campagnes
qui ont été réalisées sur
ça n'arrive pas
si ça arrive qui ont été réalisés sur
les côtes des Pays-Bas par exemple
pour certaines espèces de phoques il y a
20% des individus qui sont qui ont été
identifiés comme étant associés avec des
fragments plastiques de grande taille
des cordages etc et ça peut monter
jusqu'à 60% pour certains pour certains
stades comme comme des juvéniles
donc vous allez directement à la
deuxième et donc comme présenté par
girouen à l'instant en fait c'est gros
objets
ne représentent qu'une partie
une partie du problème puisque
voilà il se
fragmente
en micro plastique en plus des
microplastiques primaires qui ont déjà
qui ont été déjà été évoqués donc
diapositives s'il vous plaît donc il
faut bien parler des micro plastiques
parce que donc il y a une très très
grande diversité de taille johann a
évoqué les la gamme de taille entre 5 mm
et un micromètre grande variabilité de
forme comme vous pouvez le voir sur les
images qui sont présentées ici et aussi
une grande variété de composition ça a
été évoqué dans la première dans la
première présentation grande variété
aussi bien en termes de polymère que en
termes d'additifs qui contribue à la
définition des
des caractéristiques des plastiques
diapositive s'il vous plaît mais tous
ces plastiques ont un point commun c'est
la capacité d'être ingéré donc là je
vais vous présenter je vais survoler
les effets des microplastiques j'ai
choisi d'utiliser différents d'illustrer
ça avec différents niveaux de la chaîne
trophique
plutôt que de focaliser sur un sur un
niveau et donc
tous les tous les organismes de la
chaîne trophique qui sont qui sont
capables d'ingérer ce nourrir ont la
capacité d'ingérer des microplastiques
en tout cas ça a été démontré pour tous
les organismes chez lesquels on a
regardé évidemment il y a une relation
entre la taille des des organismes et la
taille des microplastiques qu'ils
peuvent ingérer donc là typiquement sur
les diapositives sur les images qui sont
montrés là on parle de microplastiques
de quelques micromètres ingérés par des
organismes de quelques centaines de
micromètres pour les deux à gauche des
artemias ou des ou des larves de
mollusques ou quelques millimètres comme
présenté à droite pour des larves de
poissons si vous cliquez normalement la
vidéo se lance voilà par contre il y a
un élément qui est essentiel à prendre
en compte c'est qu'il n'y a pas
d'accumulation des microplastiques donc
là on voit le tube digestif de
ça a été assez brutal donc le tube
digestif des on voyait le plastique dans
le tube digestif des poissons et en fait
le tous les tous les plastiques ingérés
finalement sont évacués donc il y a pas
de d'accumulation et la translocation
c'est à dire le passage dans les tissus
en fait n'est limité que au tout petit
micro plastique ou au nanoplastiques
cependant comme la source et ça a été
bien démontré par gerwan à l'instant la
source et permanente et pratiquement
infinie
en fait les organismes sont soumis à un
flux continu de plastique qui les
traverse en permanence
donc ce qui revient en fait à une
exposition permanente il y a positive
donc maintenant je vais vous illustrer
quelques
[Musique]
les impacts des microplastiques sur
quelques niveaux de la chaîne trophique
donc en commençant à la base sur le
plancton donc vous avez la chaîne
trophique qui est rappelé en haut en
haut à droite
donc le plancton ici du ici du
zooplancton donc différentes deux
expériences sont rapportées ici sur le
tableau de gauche vous voyez ne rend pas
la peine de rentrer dans le détail mais
en fait l'idée est de souligner le fait
que dans des expériences que nous avons
réalisées avec des expositions aiguës
qui correspondent à des tests
réglementaires nous n'avons mis en
évidence aucune toxicité pour ces
différents organismes là qui sont tous
des eaux plancton y compris à des
concentrations qui sont sans commune
mesure avec ce qui est observé dans
l'environnement par contre quand on
réalise des expositions de plus longue
durée donc c'est ce qui est présenté sur
la partie de droite de plusieurs jours
et bien donc c'est des collègues anglais
qui ont réalisé ça avec un copie pod et
bien on observe au bout d'un certain
nombre des altérations physiologiques
ici une diminution du taux d'ingestion
de nourriture par les copeuds explosé au
microplastiques et puis sur le le graphe
qui est en bas une diminution de la
taille des œufs qui apparaît
progressivement au bout du septième jour
et ce n'est pas visible avant donc pour
le zooplancton il y a pas de toxicité
ces exemples montrent qu'il n'y a pas de
toxicité pour des expositions de courte
durée mais que celle-ci apparaît
progressivement pour des expositions
plus longues diapositives
donc on monte un petit peu dans la
chaîne trophique cette fois-ci
on s'intéressant à des à des mollusques
en l'occurrence des huîtres donc deux
expériences ici sont présentées
pour présenter les effets à l'échelle
individuelle des organismes c'est-à-dire
au niveau du fonctionnement des
organismes donc dans les graves du haut
représentent les effets d'une exposition
à des lixivia de pneus donc c'est à dire
des ça revient en fait des extraits des
composants qui sont présents dans les
pneus qu'on peut en chimiques et donc là
vous voyez l'exposition qui met en
évidence des altérations physiologiques
donc de gauche à droite le la capacité
de filtration
le taux de respiration et puis une
variable qui est assimilée au potentiel
de croissance donc vous voyez toutes les
trois conditions en bleu foncé
et sur les deux graphes qui sont
présentés en dessous ce sont des huîtres
perlières qui ont été exposées à des
particules extraits enfin résultant du
broyage de matériaux plastiques utilisés
en perliculture donc leur environnement
non naturel mais habituel
et donc cette exposition produit à une
malformation à l'apparition de
malformations au niveau de la coquille
et une diminution de la qualité des
perles donc sur le graphe qui est
présenté à droite donc cette ces
exemples là montrent que la toxicité
peut être liée soit à l'ingestion des
microplastiques soit au chimiques qu'ils
contiennent diapositives
un deuxième exemple sur sur les huîtres
donc en haut pour illustrer en haut à
droite enfin en haut pardon
à l'apparition de malformations au
niveau de la coquille et une diminution
de la qualité des perles donc sur le
graphe qui est présenté à droite donc
cette ces exemples là montrent que la
toxicité peut être liée soit à
l'ingestion des microplastiques soit au
chimiques qu'ils contiennent
diapositives
un deuxième exemple sur sur les huîtres
donc en haut pour illustrer en haut à
droite enfin en haut pardon
mais ce qui me paraît intéressant ici
c'est de regarder le tableau du milieu
où on voit à chaque fois deux lignes
avec un figurer noir foncé et puis un
figuré clair et en fait cela représente
les lixivia obtenus à partir du matériau
9 ou du matériau vieilli et donc
systématiquement que ce soit pour les
pneus le terrain de sport ou les
élastiques on voit que le matériau 9
entraîne une toxicité plus élevée
l'exposition au lixivia de batailles en
9 entraîne une toxicité plus élevée que
celle des matériaux vieillis donc la
toxicité dépend de l'âge des matériaux
ça c'est le premier conclusion de cette
diapositive et la deuxième diapo la
deuxième partie c'est la partie du bas
ou en fait ce sont des gamètes d'huîtres
cette fois-ci qui ont été exposés à des
particules de taille différente pour le
graphe de gauche 500 nanomètres et pour
les 3 grappes de droite
des particules de 50 nanomètres donc là
on est dans le domaine des
nanoplastiques et vous voyez une
diminution du taux de fécondation qui
est
une diminution du Trophée fondation
n'est observé que pour les particules de
50 nm et pas pour celles de 500 nm donc
cet exemple précis illustre le fait que
la toxicité dépend de la taille des
particules avec une tendance au fait que
les particules plus petites sont plus
toxiques que les particules plus grosses
diapositives merci
donc maintenant je vais vous présenter
quelques résultats que nous avons
obtenus au laboratoire avec des
collègues de l'Université de Bordeaux
sur des poissons donc nous avons
exposé des poissons deux espèces de
poissons une d'eau douce et une marine à
4 plastique de polymère industriels le
PE le PVC et puis des plastiques
collectés sur deux plages de Guadeloupe
de plages différentes et pour les
plastiques industriels nous les avons en
plus enrobés avec des chimiques
et donc nous avons exposé nos poissons
pendant plusieurs mois en commençant au
premier stade de développement et donc
là je vous présente les résultats de
croissance donc premier mois pas de
différence deuxième mois pas de
différence mais finalement au bout de
quatre mois et demi d'exposition en
particulier pour les femelles nous avons
mis en évidence une diminution
significative de l'ordre de 15 à 20% de
de la croissance
diapositive donc un effet qui apparaît
au bout d'une exposition d'une
exposition chronique et qu'on ne peut
pas imaginer en tout cas sur les
premiers les premières mesures que nous
avons faites diapositives
donc je vous avais dit qu'on a utilisé
deux espèces donc on observe les mêmes
effets pour les deux espèces donc il y a
pas de relation il n'y a pas de
dépendance par rapport à l'espèce ou au
milieu au dos au eau de mer diapositives
indépendant du polymère là je vous
présente l'exemple pour une des espèces
pour le PVC qui est comparé au PE donc
pas de différence et dernière voilà
merci et ici on a l'exposition au
plastique collecté sur les sur les deux
plages donc manifestement ce que nous
avons observé chez les poisons résulte
les poissons pardon résulte d'un effet
générique qui est indépendant du
polymère qui est indépendant des
chimiques absorbés ou de l'origine il y
a positive nous sommes également
intéressés aux effets que cette
exposition pouvait avoir sur la
reproduction et donc nous avons mis en
évidence une diminution du nombre de
ponces qui illustré par les barres bleus
mais par contre cette fois-ci il y a des
différences entre les polymères pour les
polyéthylène par exemple semi observé
que quand le polyèdre polyéthylène est
absorbé avec un chimie par contre pour
le PVC qui est un des plastiques
contenant le plus additif il est observé
quel que soit enfin avec ou sans la
présence
de chimie 400 B et dans le cadre des
plastiques collectés sur sur les plages
on nous l'avons observé que avec un un
plastique donc manifestement des
mécanismes les mécanismes mis en jeu
sont différents des mécanismes mis en
jeu pour la réduction de la croissance
diapositive et un dernier exemple donc
on utilisant pour illustrer cette
fois-ci un des plus hauts maillons de la
chaîne de la chaîne trophique donc un
oiseau le plus fin c'est un article qui
a été publié récemment et qui a été
assez commenté donc des donc c'est un
oiseau marin donc qui se collecte qui se
nourrit pardon de de poissons qui va
pêcher et à cette occasion il ingère il
ingère des micros et macropastiques et
donc des collègues australiens ont
analysé le contenu de l'estomac et du
gésier
en termes de micro plastiques
chez les jeunes oiseaux pardon de 80 à
90 jours donc juste au moment où ils
vont sortir du nid donc ça veut dire que
c'est ces jeunes oiseaux n'ont été
nourris que par les parents donc pas de
nourriture indépendante de leur part
donc ça veut dire que ça reflète ce que
les parents ont mangé dans leur dans
leur environnement proche
et donc les collègues ont établi une
corrélation entre le nombre ou la masse
de plastique présente dans
donc dans les dans ces oiseaux là et la
présence d'une fibrose au niveau de
l'estomac et également une corrélation
entre outre la présence la sévérité de
la fibrose et à l'inverse ils ont mis
une évidence en évidence une corrélation
négative entre la quantité de plastique
identifiée dans ses oiseaux là et la
masse corporelle qui pouvait avoir au
moment où ils ont été analysés
diapositives donc pour conclure une
exposition chronique à des micro
plastiques conduit à des effets à long
terme c'est perturbations
touchent notamment la croissance et la
reproduction ça a été identifié aussi
bien chez les copepotes que chez les
huîtres que chez les poissons donc ça
touche tous les niveaux de la chaîne
trophique
il y a des différences en termes de
toxicité puisqu'elles dépend de la durée
d'exposition on a vu qu'une exposition
longue entraînée des effets plus
importants ou des effets tout court par
rapport à une exposition courte la
toxicité dépend également de la nature
des plastiques de l'âge des matériaux de
leur taille les mécanismes restent
néanmoins mal connues puisque
[Musique]
il y a à la fois
une participation des faits physiques
comme on l'a vu avec la fibrose par
exemple mais ça c'est pas forcément
invisible c'est toutes les espèces il y
a des effets chimiques qui peuvent
défendre dépendre à la fois des
polymères et des additifs une des
hypothèses et que cette une partie des
effets observés dépendent enfin résulte
d'une perturbation de l'équilibre
énergétique qui pourrait impliquer une
partie passion du microbiote mais je
vais pas en parler plus puisque Muriel
va faire ça dans quelques minutes
et diapositive
donc ça c'était une diapositive de
perspective mais on voilà comme présente
ici les gens qui ont participé à ces
projets et toutes les sources de
financement qui ont pu donc on a pu
bénéficier pour réaliser ses projets
sachant qu'il reste encore pas mal
d'inconnus je vous remercie
merci beaucoup pour cette présentation
et notre dernière intervenante dans
cette première table ronde et Madame
Muriel Mercier Bonin directrice de
recherche à l'inrae dans l'unité mixte
de recherche toxalim un centre de
recherche en toxicologie alimentaire
nous avons vu que la pollution plastique
affecte les écosystèmes elle a également
un impact négatif sur la santé humaine
voilà merci Bona va nous expliquer
comment l'écosystème digestif humain est
exposé au microplastiques et
potentiellement au nanoplastiques et
quels sont les impacts potentiels merci
merci madame la sénatrice donc bonjour à
toutes et à tous et donc comme ça a été
dit je vais aujourd'hui vous présenter
un exemple en fait de recherche
interdisciplinaire que qu'on mène à
toxalisme et avec nous nos
collaborateurs sur l'impact en fait des
micros voire des nanoplastiques dans
l'environnement digestif humain donc par
rapport aux trois sources en fait
d'exposition potentielle chez l'homme
ingestion inhalation et contact par la
peau donc mon exposé va se centrer plus
particulièrement sur la voie orale donc
l'ingestion diapositif suivante donc ce
qui est bien de passer après mes
collègues c'est de voilà c'est que ils
ont déjà donné des notions en fait des
concepts de base par rapport à qu'est-ce
que un micro plastique et qu'est-ce
qu'un anneau plastique donc on a
beaucoup parlé de de la question de
taille c'est-à-dire que un micro
plastique il est défini entre une taille
de 1 micromètre jusqu'à 5 mm donc là
j'ai illustré une un travail que j'aime
bien qui qui montre que c'est vrai que
c'est il y a des travaux justement qui
sont pas forcément consensuels sur ces
notions de taille notamment par rapport
aux nanoplastiques qui sont définies de
manière
récente comme une particule qui a une
taille inférieure à un micromètre parce
que un anneau plastique ce n'est ni un
micro plastique ni une nanoparticules au
sens des nanopatériaux par exemple que
comme le dioxyde de titane mais comme la
souligner
un Xavier juste avant un micro plastique
ou un anneau plastique ce n'est pas
qu'une question de taille mais c'est
également une question de de type de
polymère qui va composer ces particules
plastiques la notion d'additif la notion
de morphologie mais également la notion
de de vecteurs parce que un micro ou un
anneau plastique il va pouvoir aussi le
durant le son cycle de vie absorbé
certains toxines certains composés
chimiques que ce soit des polluants
environnementaux ou des métaux lourds
donc diapositive suivante s'il vous
plaît donc par rapport à la
problématique qui nous occupe maintenant
autour de la santé humaine santé humaine
pardon pour moi en fait je la
qualifierais de thématiques très
émergentes mais très active au niveau
français mais également européen voire
international donc pour illustrer en
fait cette problématique de l'impact en
santé humaine j'ai choisi de vous
présenter sur la sur la partie de gauche
une enquête qui avait été réalisée par
lève ça en 2019 pour essayer de voir en
fait la perception des citoyens
européens sur la sécurité sanitaire des
aliments donc c'est un neurobaromètre
qui portait sur une quinzaine en fait
d'objets d'études donc que ce soit des
additifs ou des contaminants
alimentaires des pesticides des nanomes
matériaux et donc en fait ils avaient
interrogé donc les ben voilà le panel de
de citoyens sur leur perception de la de
la présence des microplastiques dans
l'alimentation et ce que vous voyez dans
la dans la cartographie c'est qu'il y
avait vraiment une
répartition qui dépendait des pays
certains pays notamment donc en Europe
du Nord les citoyens étaient vraiment
très conscients des enjeux autour de la
présence des microplastiques dans
l'aliment contrairement à d'autres pays
comme par exemple la Grèce ou Chypre et
ce qui est dans cette étude qui était
aussi intéressant c'était que le niveau
d'éducation pouvait intervenir dans la
perception de la présence de ces
microplastiques dans dans les aliments
alors cette thématique de la des micros
et nanoplastiques dans en santé humaine
donc j'aime à dire que que c'est une
thématique qui est en lien avec des
enjeux politiques économiques et
sociétaux autour de la pollution
plastique donc je vous ai illustré en
fait dans un dans le graphique en bas à
droite
l'état des connaissances scientifiques
sur les impacts avec un focus la plus
particulièrement sur la santé digestive
qui est le cœur de l'exposé aujourd'hui
où on voit que en 2015 on avait aucune
connaissance sur les impacts anciennes
des microplastiques donc ça ce sont les
barres en bleu et on voit que depuis
2017 il y a un accélération de la
connaissance dans le dans le domaine et
en rouge c'est la thématique des
nanoplastiques où on voit que là c'est
un embryon en fait de recherche les
communautés commencent à se structurer
mais c'est vraiment très très émergent
donc cette connaissance scientifique
pour moi elle doit aussi s'articuler
comme je l'ai dit sur les enjeux
politiques économiques et sociétaux qui
sont déclinés à la fois à l'échelle
européenne via lève ça par exemple sur
ces sur les rapports qui peut faire sur
la présence des microlanoplastiques dans
l'alimentation également tout ce qui est
stratégie européenne pour l'économie
circulaire le pacte vert de manière plus
récente mais également au niveau
français avec ses lois la loi AGEC le
rapport du CESU plus récemment et aussi
l'ambition en fait en 2040 d'avoir voilà
le zéro déchet plastique et aujourd'hui
on s'inscrit également dans cette dans
cette négociation autour d'un traité
mondial pour mettre fin à la pollution
plastique et voir voilà de prendre en
compte les enjeux qui sont autour de des
impacts en santé humaine
diapositive suivante s'il vous plaît
donc quand on s'intéresse en fait à la
santé humaine et bien on veut savoir
quel est le voilà quel est le risque
pour notre santé d'être exposé
quotidiennement au micro et au
nanoplastiques et là force c'est de
constater que pour l'instant
l'évaluation du risque elle est à ce
stade des connaissances scientifiques
impossibles donc là c'est ce que je vous
ai illustré dans une voilà dans un dans
une une article qui est parue récemment
pour l'instant en fait en termes de
d'évaluation du risque c'est tout
simplement pas possible parce qu'il y a
des gros verrous scientifiques encore à
lever donc là ça fait l'objet en fait
d'une parution dans un dans un journal
enfin voilà dans un article antique dans
Science en 21 c'est qu'on a encore des
des verrous cognitifs méthodologiques et
scientifiques autour des dangers liés à
l'exposition aux effets toxicologiques à
la difficulté de détecter les micros et
les nanoplastiques de petites tailles
dans les fluides biologiques donc tout
ça ça
ce sont des encore des des freins à la
connaissance et on espère que voilà la
Commission européenne en 2020 elle a
financé 5 projets qui qui auront pour
objectif justement d'aller vers une
meilleure évaluation du risque en santé
humaine donc un risque c'est
l'association d'un danger donc d'un
effet toxicologique mais aussi d'une
exposition humaine donc là je vous ai je
vous ai mis un petit peu un historique
en fait depuis 2019 par rapport à cette
fameuse histoire de la carte de crédit
qu'on serait amené à consommer par
semaine donc c'est 5G par semaine
rappelez-vous il y a eu un impact un
écho médiatique mais vraiment
extraordinaire très fort mais pour nous
en tant que scientifique la
concrétisation elle passe par la
publication de la de l'article qui fait
référence à ces 5 grammes par semaine
donc en 2021 donc soit deux ans après
est paru l'article et là en fait les
conclusions sont un peu plus
mitigés en ce sens ou en fonction des
scénarios d'exposition on ne serait
plutôt dans une fourchette qui va de 0,1
à 5 g par semaine donc c'était une
première pierre à un édifice c'est à
dire que pour pour les designer en fait
des expérimentations il faut connaître
en fait ces doses à laquelle on serait
amené à être exposé mais en fait
récemment depuis un an ou deux ces
chiffres là de 0,1 à 5 g par semaine ils
sont discutés et donc je trouvais
important aujourd'hui de vous de vous
donner aussi cet éclairage à propos de
cette voilà de cette carte de crédit et
voir qu'on n'est pas peut-être pas amené
à consommer une carte de crédit par
semaine mais plutôt 23000 ans dans le
cas d'un d'une d'un article qui a été
publié très récemment en fait par par un
collègue autrichien et qui dit que voilà
c'est pas une semaine mais c'est 23000
ans dans une vie ça fait peut-être un
petit peu long pour ingérer 5 g donc il
y a d'autres travaux qui sont sur voilà
plutôt sur enfin à gauche là où ils ont
fait
à partir de différents types de
d'aliments donc l'étude en fait de Nord
en 2021 c'était sur les poissons les
mollusques les crustacés l'eau du
robinet l'eau en bouteille la bière le
lait le sel et l'air Isaac isestime en
fait que ce serait plutôt de l'ordre de
4 microgrammes par semaine donc voyons
on est loin des 5 g par semaine et une
étude plus récente encore en 2023 là
plus sur une population coréenne donc
avec un régime alimentaire adapté à la
Corée donc là ils étaient sur 80
produits
issus de différents types de de
d'aliments comme les sols le sel les
sauces les fruits de mer les algues le
miel le bière et les boissons donc là ce
serait plutôt entre 140 et 310
microgrammes par semaine donc proche en
fait du même de grandeur que l'étude de
Nord donc là ce qu'il faut garder à
l'esprit aujourd'hui c'est qu'on a
encore de grosses incertitudes en termes
d'exposition parce que en fonction des
sources de données à laquelle on fait
référence ou aux méthodes d'estimation
on peut avoir des gros écarts dans les
dans les dans les doses à laquelle nous
sommes exposés de manière quotidienne
diapositive suivante
donc là je vous ai remis en fait un
petit une petite synthèse de qu'est-ce
qui est connu actuellement sur
l'exposition orale et l'impact donc là
on est plus sur les micro plastiques
dans le tractus gastro-intestinal donc
chez l'adulte ce qui est connu en fait
c'est même si les travaux ils sont en
train d'être complétés pour les
différentes matrices ou aliments à
laquelle auxquels enfin lesquels on
ingère quotidiennement dans ce qu'on
sait c'est qu'on va les retrouver dans
l'eau et les boissons mais également un
certain type d'aliments donc on en a
parlé tout à l'heure les produits de la
mer les poissons mais également le sel
la bière les fruits et légumes on va les
retrouver aussi dans dans les emballages
qui sont une source directe d'émissions
de microplastiques un micro plastique on
l'a dit c'est un polymère c'est un
additif mais c'est seulement un vecteur
d'autres polluants par rapport à l'effet
cheval de Troie donc chez l'enfant qui a
une population chez laquelle on a aussi
travaillé donc là les sources de
d'exposition elles sont aussi présentes
parce qu'on peut en retrouver dans les
biberons dans les tétines dans les
jouets dans la dans la poussière mais
également il y a des travaux récents qui
tendraient à démontrer qu'on retrouve
des microplastiques dans le lait
maternel donc une fois qu'on va ingérer
en fait ces micro plastiques donc ce que
je vous ai pas dit c'est que sur les
nanoplastiques donc là il y a encore
très très peu de données il y a un
article récent qui est paru sur sur
l'eau du robinet et également au niveau
de certains emballages mais c'est vrai
que là pour l'instant les données sont
très très peu documentées mais une fois
qu'on va ingérer en fait ces micro
plastiques ce qu'on sait c'est qu'il y a
une diversité de polymère une diversité
de taille et de forme une fois qu'on va
être voilà on va ingérer ses formes il
va y avoir au niveau de la digestion les
premières étapes de la digestion donc de
la bouche jusqu'au parti haute de du
tractus Gastro Intestinal on va avoir
une dégradation physico-chimique ou pas
en fonction du type de polymère ce qu'on
sait c'est qu'on peut avoir aussi une
formation autour de autour de ces mic
pratique d'une couronne biomoléculaire
qui peut aussi après avoir un impact sur
les mécanismes de translocation au
niveau d'une barrière intestinale ce
qu'il a été montré une vitraux c'est
qu'on peut avoir aussi une altération de
la digestion des lipides ce qui peut
aussi avoir un impact après sur
l'homéostasie au niveau de au niveau de
la digestion si on regarde après en bout
de chaîne entre guillemets ce qu'on va
scruter au niveau des sels humaines donc
ça c'est des travaux qui ont été menés à
partir de 2019 où on va retrouver en
fait ça c'est avéré des particules de
microplastiques avec différentes chimies
donc du PET du polypropylène et ce qui
est aussi très intéressant c'est que
dans certaines populations sensibles
notamment en fait chez les enfants on va
retrouver une augmentation des
microplastiques notamment sur des
microplastiques en PET et on a retrouvé
également une augmentation des
microplastiques chez certains patients
donc là je vous ai mis les patients Miki
donc Miki ça veut dire maladie
inflammatoire chronique de l'intestin
donc ça concerne en fait des pathologies
de type maladie de Crohn ou rectocolite
hémorragiques et là chez ses patients on
a retrouvé plus de microplastiques donc
nous au niveau du laboratoire on
travaille sur la barrière intestinale
donc c'est ce que je vous ai présenté
donc c'est c'est le la barrière en fait
protectrice au niveau de notre
homoteasie et donc cette barrière
intestinale elle est elle est composée
de trois acteurs que sont l'épithélium
le mucus et le microbiote donc dans la
littérature également laboratoire on
travaille sur des modèles in vivo donc
animaux mais également des des
digesteurs in vitro donc c'est ce que je
vous présentais aujourd'hui et on a
travaillé à la fois chez l'adulte et
chez l'enfant donc quand on a commencé
notre étude il y avait une seule étude
qui portait sur des des
digesteurs à partir de celle humaine et
donc là en fait c'était uniquement un
modèle colique avec une des micro
plastiques en polyéthylène téréphtalate
et ils avaient montré en fait dans le
cas d'une exposition aiguë des effets
compartiments et donneurs dépendants
donc nous par rapport à cette à ce à
cette synthèse une diapositive suivante
on a travaillé en fait dans des modèles
in vitro donc ces modèles in vitro c'est
globalement un bioréacteur instrumenté
où on va réguler en fait l'ensemble des
paramètres physico-chimiques et
microbiens qui régissent le les
l'écosystème digestif humain au niveau
de notre colon donc on a appelé ça le
muco mucosal artificial colon donc on a
travaillé chez l'adulte et chez l'enfant
donc pour ça on a appris en fait deux
enfin quatre donneurs de femmes et et
deux hommes ou deux filles et deux
garçons on a travaillé en fait sur des
microplastiques en polyéthylène dans de
d'origine commerciale donc ces
microplastiques ils avaient une forme
sphérique et on était à une dose
journalière de l'ordre de 21 mg par jour
et comme l'a dit tout à l'heure Xavier
vous savez que c'est important aussi
d'avoir une exposition chronique donc
nous on a fait 14 jours d'exposition
avec une administration quotidienne dans
le bioréacteur et on a pu regarder au
niveau du microbiote intestinal donc le
microbiote c'est l'ensemble en fait des
micro-organismes qui sont abrités dans
notre dans notre côlon donc on a
travaillé à la fois sur la composition
du microbiote donc sa structure c'est à
dire l'ensemble en fait des bactéries
qui qui composent notre microbiote mais
également sur son activité métabolique
c'est à dire que en fait le microbiote
il va produire des métabolites qui
peuvent avoir des effets positifs ou
négatifs sur notre santé et donc là s'il
faut retenir en fait deux choses qui
sont importantes quand on compare
l'adulte et l'enfant c'est qu'on va
avoir des signatures microbiennes
communes c'est à dire qu'on a eu une
augmentation des patobiantes alors un
patobiante c'est une des bactéries qui
sont potentiellement pathogènes sous
certaines conditions et donc nous plus
particulièrement au niveau d'un
microbiote luminal c'est-à-dire le
microbiote qui est au niveau de la de la
lumière donc à l'intérieur de tube
digestif on a on a détecté en fait une
augmentation de deux populations les
détient sur le
stuffyonacées et les entérobactér
quartiers qui sont des patobiantes et ce
qu'on a trouvé également de manière très
intéressante c'est qu'on a des
signatures microbiennes vraiment
spécifiques de l'adulte et de l'enfant
c'est à dire que chez la population
adulte on a on a vu en fait une
augmentation d'un composé organique
volatile qui s'appelle le scatole et qui
avait été déjà décrit chez certains
patients qui sont atteints de
encéphalopathie hépatiques et chez les
enfants on a contrairement à l'adulte où
on a rien n'avait été modifié on a mis
en évidence une
diminution du butyrate donc en fait le
but irate c'est un acide gras à chaîne
courte qui a un effet bénéfique pour
notre santé donc c'est vrai que cette
diminution du butyrate pose question on
sait aide par rapport à l'impact des
microplastiques
et donc diapositive voilà donc ce qui
est aussi important dans cette
communication entre des microplastiques
et et le microbiote c'est que
effectivement le microbiote il peut être
impacté par les micro plastiques mais
lui il peut également avoir une mais
également les le microbiote il peut en
fait aussi avoir des capacités de
dégradation de biodégradation des des
plastiques des microplastiques en
polyéthylène donc on a commencé par
faire de la microscopie électronique
donc là vous voyez les images où on voit
les grosses billes en fait ce sont nos
microplastiques et les petites billes ou
les petits bâtonnets ce sont les
bactéries en fait qui sont adhérer à la
surface des microplastiques et donc on
s'est dit ces bactéries adhérer est-ce
qu'elles peuvent dégrader en fait le
polyéthylène sachant que le polytyrène
c'est quand même très très stable donc
pour ce faire en fait on a fait de la
spectroscopiemment avec des collègues
qui sont voilà qui sont chimistes et
analyticiens donc la spectroscopie
ramasse une spectroscopie vibrationnelle
qui permet d'avoir une signature
chimique des microplastiques et là en
fait ce qu'on a obtenu c'est que
globalement dans le cas du polyéthylène
on avait très peu de modifications
physico-chimiques des microplastiques
liés à l'interaction entre les
microplastiques et les bactéries et on a
également fait en fait des contacts de
nos digestats sur des modèles
cellulaires qui miment en fait la
barrière mucus épithélium et là on a
observé des effets mineurs mais qui
était aussi d'honneur dépendants sur
l'épithélium et le mucus
alors juste voilà diapositive suivante
et ce sera ma diapositive de conclusion
et proposer quelques pistes futures de
recherche donc ce qu'il faut garder à
l'esprit par rapport à cette thématique
de micro et nanoplastiques et santé
digestive que c'est vraiment un
challenge interdisciplinaire que là en
fait j'ai choisi d'illustrer à cette
interface entre la toxicologie et la
chimie donc au niveau de la toxicologie
il va falloir en fait aussi qu'on pourra
aller au-delà de ce que je vous ai
présenté aujourd'hui c'est avoir des
nouveaux modèles expérimentaux pour
justement mieux appréhender cette
problématique qui est vraiment complexe
aussi mimer en fait d'autres
problématiques autour de la
communication entre les organes parce
que l'intestin en fait il est central il
communique avec le foie il communique
avec le cerveau il communique aussi avec
le poumon donc cette problématique en
fait autour de l'intestin elle se
décline aussi dans une communication
avec d'autres organes et l'autre chose
qui est vraiment importante à aborder
au-delà de ce que je vous ai présenté
aujourd'hui sur les enfants c'est qu'on
doit aussi s'intéresser à des
populations à risque avec la notion
d'exposome c'est à dire que durant tout
le cycle de vie l'humain est exposé à un
certain nombre de facteurs
environnementaux et donc là on a un
projet qu'on espère sera financer par la
NR autour de regarder l'impact en fait
chez des populations qui sont soumises
un régime occidental et qui ont à la
fois une variable fragilisée au niveau
de l'intestin et un microbiote 10
biotique c'est-à-dire un microbiote
déséquilibré et au niveau de la chimie
ce qui est vraiment important par
rapport à la chimie la chimie de
synthèse la chimie analytique c'est
d'avoir accès aux différentes sources de
contamination par les microplastiques
mais également par les nanoplastiques
pour avoir des meilleures données
d'exposition humaine comme je vous l'ai
dit c'est vrai que le champ il est
complètement en fait encore ouvert par
rapport à ces doses à laquelle on est
exposé il faut également travailler avec
nos collègues chimistes sur des modèles
représentatifs en termes de forme en
termes de taille en termes de polymère
et de d'additifs mais également l'effet
vecteur c'est vraiment quelque chose
d'important à creuser et également aussi
développer des méthodes analytiques qui
soient fiables qui soient robustes pour
dans les milieux complexes que sont les
fluides biologiques les petites
particules et là par rapport à ça donc
on a une collaboration dans le cadre
d'un cosplay avec des collègues en
Sicile également je vous ai mis un petit
focus sur les grands instruments c'est à
dire les rayonnements synchrotron qui a
Gif-sur-Yvette pas très loin d'ici en au
synchrotron soleil pour justement sonder
sonder la matière par la lumière il y a
beaucoup beaucoup de de d'exploration
possible par rapport à ces grands
instruments voilà et oui pour finir en
fait moi j'aime bien cette phrase donc
je voulais vous la livrer aussi c'est
que voilà dans une dans une logique
interdisciplinaire since happenwhen we
share or vision voilà donc je trouve que
c'est vraiment ce qu'il faut faire pour
pour la suite au niveau de la recherche
scientifique voilà et je voudrais juste
faire terminer par par les collègues
avec qui on travaille voilà et notamment
les doctorants qui sont les forces vives
de la recherche d'aujourd'hui et de
demain voilà merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup pour toutes ces
présentations alors c'est vrai que à la
lumière de tout ce que vous venez de
nous exposer on est avec Philippe bien
sûr complètement
dans le sens de ce qu'on avait mis comme
titre c'est à dire une bombe à
retardement et on envoie à l'époque
quand on avait fait nos notre
on a eu mené notre rapport on avait un
petit peu moins de connaissances là vous
nous avez donné encore plus de raison en
fait à ce titre qui s'avère presque une
apocalypse plastique par l'accumulation
et surtout ce qu'on vient de découvrir
que que enfin je pense à Philippe on ne
connaissait pas c'est l'impact
millénaire que vont avoir les plastiques
avec leur fragmentation en morceaux de
plus en plus petit et on vient de voir
que les impacts quand les plastiques
sont plus petits
des impacts en tout cas santé chez nous
mais bien évidemment sur toute la
biodiversité ce qui est déjà documenté
alors moi je vais pas mobiliser puisque
on a des collègues qui sont là et qui
voudront peut-être poser des questions
on commence donc à se faire une image
plus nette de la réalité de la pollution
plastique mais on n'est pas encore
arrivé au bout peut-être quand deux
trois mots même si notre dernière
intervenante a déjà esquissé le futur
des recherches possibles ce qui serait
nécessaire de faire
et parce que
très clairement parce qu'on est nous
sommes des politiques de comment
diffuser cette connaissance au niveau de
des preneurs de décision que nous sommes
même si nous avec Philippe on est bien
évidemment on a on a bien compris les
choses et comment faire aussi et ça a
été un peu évoqué avec les citoyens pour
leur faire prendre conscience et
peut-être les amener dans leur
consommation à être plus regardant
parce que comme vous l'avez dit le flux
plastique est très très enfin
énormissime
que toutes ces matières ont été mises
sur le marché avec des produits
chimiques les additifs les plastifiants
sans qu'on ait mesuré l'impact salé à
voir et parce qu'on pensait
ou pas qui n'allait pas être relié mais
là maintenant on est devant le fait
accompli ces produits sont relargués ils
posent de gros problèmes et puis le flux
tellement important du plastique
évidemment un impact sur la biodiversité
sur notre santé qu'on ne peut plus ne
pas voir voilà donc juste si vous voulez
intervenir rapidement puis après je
demanderai à mes collègues s'ils veulent
donc vous poser des questions
répondre
sur la suite qu'il faudrait donner en
fait est-ce qu'il y a encore des choses
à documenter même si on a déjà documenté
beaucoup pour que la prise de conscience
à tous les niveaux citoyens politiques
décideurs soit à la hauteur des enjeux
de cette pollution
beaucoup de temps ou peut-être l'espace
pour dire qu'est-ce qu'il faut comme
recherche une typhique mais la
discussion en internationale qui se pose
c'est surtout que l'approche prend au
niveau des politiques prends un approche
accès sur les risques même au sur la
dangerosité dont les principes de
précautions et important il s'avère
nécessaire donc j'avais donné un exemple
de non data sans donner il y a pas
marché et il y a certains de ces simples
chez les plastiques par exemple par
quand le plastique est en contact avec
les avec les avec les aliments il y a
des approches qu'on appelle des listes
positives c'est à dire c'est que les
substances qui se trouvent pas que se
trouvent dans la liste c'est le
substances qui sont permis pour utiliser
quand les matériels les produits et
contrairement à la liste négative que on
voit normalement chez chez les lois de
des plastiques à ustache unique donc
mais aussi dans la liste des produits
chimiques qui ont dit c'est ça qu'on
peut utiliser on appelle des blacklist
de liste noire mais
on approche un peu hybride ça par
intéressant en disant on peut commencer
on n'a pas encore tous les données et ça
c'est un problème d'un approche accès
sur les risques il accessibilité de ces
données mais ce que doit agir maintenant
au niveau des précautions et c'est dans
ces débats qu'on se trouve en niveau
international on pense que ça c'est
c'est un peu la voix et les schémas
merci
est-ce que je peux intervenir
ah oui bien sûr oui
pour avoir une métaphore simple si votre
baignoire déborde la première chose que
vous faites c'est pas d'aller chercher
des serpillières c'est de fermer l'eau
et c'est peut-être c'est simpliste je
pense que il faut vraiment se poser la
question là lorsque
g Owen nous explique que même si on
arrête tout en 2040 ça va continuer
pendant des centaines et des milliers
d'années et que on voit le chiffre que
ça va non pas s'arrêter en 2040 mais ça
va augmenter de manière exponentielle là
on est dans une situation où
ça déborde il y a
un risque direct pour la santé à tous
les niveaux et on est en train de
continuer à rajouter du plastique donc
ça c'est à mon avis la première chose à
laquelle il faut s'attaquer c'est-à-dire
s'attaquer à l'augmentation de la
production et de l'utilisation du
plastique parce que autrement on va se
retrouver à vouloir mettre des des
feux de réparer des choses qui c'est pas
possible c'est ça ne fera pas suffire
parce qu'on sera on sera à la traîne on
sera la remorque donc je pense qu'il
faut se poser la question de où peut-on
commencer à supprimer le plastique ou
peut-on continuer à supprimer le
plastique et éventuellement arriver
quels sont les endroits où le plastique
est quand même bien plus intéressant que
risque qu'un risque
il y a des collègues qui veulent merci
qui veulent poser des questions
moi j'aurai une question
à poser sur justement la liste des
produits chimiques qui sont donc
maintenant
interdit ou limité il y en a apparemment
beaucoup d'autres que faudrait-il faire
à votre avis sur comment
documenter tout cela puisque il y a des
milliers de substances chimiques qui
posent problème comment faire pour aller
suffisamment rapidement par rapport aux
risques que nous prenons tous finalement
dans ce dans cette optique là avec tous
ces produits et notamment également avec
les secrets industriels qui font que
nous ne connaissons pas forcément tous
les produits qui sont ajoutés au
plastique et qui pourtant vont arriver
dans l'environnement où vont impacter la
biodiversité lorsque ces produits sont
reliés
donc voilà je sais pas si quelqu'un peut
répondre
la parole mais il y a déjà des exemples
nouvelles de Laos ce qu'on appelle mat
omnito le secteur data acceptation des
données au niveau mutuelle
qui permet en fait
transposer ce qu'on trouve dans des
recherches que c'est fond dans certains
juridictions peut-être au niveau
régional Union européenne
au niveau national des quels sont les
données pour permettre croisser ces
données et voir qu'est-ce qui est
interdit d'entendre juridiction il
pourrait être interdit dans un niveau
global peut-être et aussi déjà on
parlait bien tout à l'heure qu'il avait
128 130 substances qui sont contre la
niveau internationale mais on sait qu'au
niveau national est plus au niveau
régional il y a peu près 1000 substances
de ces 13000 substances qu'on parle qui
sont qui sont contrôlés
dont c'est approche des groupes de voir
les substances par une par une mais par
groupe permettra aussi de mettre
l'accent sur la rapidité nécessaire pour
combler la problématique merci
merci beaucoup et je laisse la parole à
Philippe
merci même la sénatrice une question qui
le fruit de différentes présentations
que vous nous avez fait vous avez montré
plusieurs constats de vous avez fait
plusieurs constats d'incertitude de la
recherche de d'obstacles qui sont face à
vous qui permettent pas d'aller au-delà
sur un certain nombre de conclusions
vous avez aussi pour certains présenter
des protocoles expérimentaux qui
montrent qu'il s'inscrivent dans un
champ très particulier et qui ne couvre
pas l'exhaustivité de tout ce qu'on peut
imaginer et donc ma question concerne le
travail en commun des équipes
scientifiques et l'intelligence
collective de la recherche qui
permettrait selon moi de lever les
freins d'élargir les champs des
protocoles et de d'aller vers des
faisceaux convergents à plusieurs et
donc des démonstrations plus rapides et
plus robustes qu'en est-il de ce travail
en commun existe-t-il un GIEC de la
pollution plastique comme on a le GIEC
du climat je sais qu'en France on a la
chance d'avoir le GDR polymère et océan
mais qu'en est-il au niveau
international du croisement des
recherches au niveau européen ou plus
largement au niveau mondial
n'existe pas
exactement de structures qui soit
apparentées au GIEC on l'état actuel
mais on voit bien que
le
fait que le traité les discussions sur
le traité
visant à résoudre la solution la
pollution plastique entraîne finalement
le regroupement d'un certain nombre de
scientifiques et donc il y a une
coalition de scientifique qui travaille
ensemble
qui voilà donc c'est une ça n'existe pas
encore mais c'est quelqu'un une
structure une instance qui est en train
de se formaliser ou en tout cas de
s'organiser avec la participation d'ONG
aussi dont au ciel par exemple et puis
organisation voilà qui fait intervenir
différents acteurs au-delà du monde
scientifique voilà pour répondre à ces
questions là
après ce coup ce que je peux rajouter en
fait par rapport à ce que dit Xavier
c'est que globalement il faut trouver
les espaces ou les créer nous en tant
que scientifique pour décloisonner en
fait parce que c'est vrai qu'on
travaille souvent dans un dans des silos
disciplinaires thématiques et ses
espaces en fait de co-construction de
discussions d'échanges il faut arriver à
les à les fédérer donc déjà au niveau
français enfin voilà c'est des choses
qui est peut-être travail différemment
donc vous avez parlé d'intelligence
collective dans le dans la recherche et
je trouve que moi c'est son voilà c'est
c'est des valeurs de fonctionner
différemment de travailler avec les
intelligences des uns et des autres pour
avoir un effet plus plus quoi c'est à
dire que 1 + 1 n'est pas égal de Mégal à
3 en intelligence collective donc tu as
tous très super si on arrive à le mettre
nous en œuvre en tant que scientifique
et donc il faut que voilà il faut créer
des des espaces donc le GDR au niveau
français même s'il y a des même s'il y a
des enfin voilà des des liens forts avec
notamment le les États-Unis pour essayer
de travailler ensemble sur des
problématiques autour de la pollution
plastique et des impacts donc ce GDR
c'est qui s'appelait polymère et océan
et donc il était vraiment centré sur les
océans comme son nom l'indique mais la
globalement les le renouvellement de ce
GDR a pour ambition a pour envie de
d'aller au-delà et donc il y a la santé
humaine qui a été intégrée il y a aussi
la santé des sols parce qu'on en a
beaucoup parlé voilà que la pollution
c'est pas que la pollution des océans et
des et des il y a aussi la pollution au
niveau des écosystèmes terrestres
continentaux et donc les sols c'est
vraiment une une ressource
malheureusement forte de microplastiques
vont donner nos plastiques avec des
impacts sur la sur la santé
environnementales donc on décline en
fait le concept de wannels dans ce GDR
et une seule santé et donc c'est vrai
que c'est des c'est des questions qui
nous ont qui vont nous occuper et après
la dimension internationale c'est vrai
que ben voilà elle est nécessaire parce
que ça s'arrête pas aux frontières de
notre territoire voilà
je pense qu'il y a un enjeu également
sur lequel
on peut en partie répondre à au
questionnement notamment de
l'interdiction c'est surtout les
questions de des alternatives à ces
usages je pense que on l'a vu notamment
dans les exposés des surutilisation de
plastique notamment pour les emballages
alimentaires
et peut-être un enjeu qui est
scientifique mais qui est aussi culturel
et et à la fois dans les dans les
habitudes de consommation mais mais
aussi à prendre en compte aussi dans
dans l'utilisation plus globale de des
plastiques et de ses alternatives pour
pour pouvoir mettre en avant l'ensemble
des solutions qu'on pourrait envisager à
l'avenir
je pense que traiter purement et
simplement la question de l'interdiction
c'est comme revenir dans les impasses en
tout cas d'un point de vue politique que
l'on a sur d'autres sujets
notamment concernant les intrants
alimentaires je pense qu'on a vraiment
tout intérêt à valoriser
ces alternatives et moi ma question
c'est est-ce que aujourd'hui on a des
solutions techniques
qui permettent de faire en sorte que les
usages notamment de sûreté alimentaire
puisse permettre ces alternatives c'est
transition et aussi pour que les
décisions politiques puissent être
assurés derrière face à ces enjeux
oui pour compléter la question de
monsieur le Président il y a parce qu'en
fait ça fait écho à des questions qui
ont été posées par les internautes qui
nous suivent c'est l'un d'entre eux nous
dit il y a aussi la solution des
bioplastiques qui permettrait d'adresser
notamment un certain nombre de réponses
par rapport à tout ce qui est
utilisation du pétrole et vous l'avez
souligné à deux reprises mais est-ce que
c'est une vraie ou fausse bonne idée et
puis dans le sud sur le sujet de
l'interdiction il y a une autre question
qui revient en lien avec qui peut être
lié à cette cette famille de
questionnements c'est il y a un domaine
qu'on a pas évoqué qui est un domaine on
utilise beaucoup le plastique celui de
la santé et donc dès qu'on parle
d'interdiction de substitution quid des
impasses qui peut y avoir dans le dans
le domaine de la santé avec la une
approche peut-être un peu coût bénéfice
quel est le coût pour le patient
d'utilisation du plastique par rapport
au bénéfice du sauver la vie si on
utilise une poche de sang en plastique
suite à un accident de la route
je crois que l'idée c'est pas de dire le
plastique c'est très mauvais il faut
interdire tous les plastiques il y a
certainement des
conditions ou des situations donc pour
lesquelles le plastique ne peut pas être
remplacé facilement par contre pour le
revenir sur votre histoire sur l'autre
question à propos des bioplastiques en
fait bioplastiques c'est
souvent un mélange de deux choses les
plastiques dont la matière première est
d'origine non pétrole donc en général
d'origine végétale et les plastiques de
dégradables donc les plastiques dont
l'origine et non non pétrolières en fait
finalement produisent le même type de
plastique donc la question est
enfin voilà il y a pas de différence
là-dessus et après la question des
plastiques biodégradables donc il peut
avoir différentes sources différentes
origines
une des questions essentielles c'est que
le rhinocuité pour l'instant n'a pas
réellement été démontré donc l'aspect
bénéfice en termes industriel et en
termes théorique oui d'accord mais
présentement
et il y a un certain nombre d'études qui
commencent à être réalisé et dont à
propos desquels on se rend compte que
finalement
les plastiques biodégradables ne sont
pas enfin entraînent une certaine
toxicité donc n'apparaisse pas
nécessairement comme une solution et
ensuite sur ces aspects là mais on est
un petit peu en dehors largement en
dehors de mon domaine de compétence donc
ça pourrait être complété par d'autres
mais
il y a un seul plastique biodégradable
pour l'instant qui se doit des grades en
milieu marin c'est le phbb ou cette
famille de de
plastique les autres ne se dégradent pas
en milieu marin ce qu'il faut des
conditions extrêmement particulières
pour que la biodégradation ait lieu donc
finalement c'est pas
nécessairement une solution
à court terme
sachant que c'est
c'est une c'est un sujet c'est un sujet
que nous voulons aborder dans un projet
c'est à dire que oui dans le cadre des
plastiques biodégradables donc c'est
qu'on a fait une demande de financement
commune avec avec Xavier autour de
justement cette fragmentation de ces
impacts sur sur les modèles sur lesquels
ils travaillent voilà dans une
problématique
plutôt marine mais c'est vrai que ça
pose aussi des soucis
il y a les
c'est un grand sujet je pense que si on
commence à l'ouvrir
c'est une boîte qui est importante c'est
vrai que le biodégradable il faut juste
rappeler quand même que le plastique
pose problème parce qu'il n'est pas
biodégradable et que souvent on a
tendance à l'oublier qu'il y a eu une
grosse confusion au niveau des thermes
employés et notamment de la définition
des biodégradables il se rappeler
surtout qu'il y a un biodégradable qui
ne l'est pas c'est qui est appelé
biodégradable mais qui n'est pas
biodégradable en conditions naturelles
c'est le plat c'est l'acide polylactique
après le terme bioplastique je pense
qu'il a proscrit complètement parce que
donc ça je crois qu'on a une bonne
explication il peut être tout simplement
biosourcer et auquel cas ça n'a
strictement aucun intérêt vis-à-vis de
la pollution plastique puisqu'on a les
mêmes problèmes en termes de pollution
par contre un vrai biodégradable oui
bien sûr et c'est pour ça qu'on a
remplacé les sacs plastiques par des
sacs papier par exemple dans les
supermarchés parce que le papier
biodégradable il s'accumule pas comme le
carton comme bois etc donc il faut pas
avoir peur du terme biodégradabilité je
pense mais il y a eu une confusion qui
entretenue et je comprends pas pourquoi
est-ce qu'il n'y a pas eu une révision
de cette définition de biodégradabilité
puisque actuellement il y a des
matériaux qui sont appelés
biodégradables alors que il doit monter
à des températures très élevées de 60
degrés pour pouvoir l'être or il
faudrait un sacré réchauffement
climatique pour espérer qu'il soit
dégradé entre environnement alors après
on va me répliquer oui mais l'objectif
c'est pas de les jeter dans
l'environnement
sauf qu'on verra peut-être dans la
deuxième table ronde que malheureusement
même si on a l'impression qu'ils sont
pas jetés parce qu'ils sont bien traités
parce qu'ils sont enfouis parce qu'ils
sont recyclés en réalité ils vont finir
par se retrouver dans l'environnement
pluralisi
mais vous posez la question mais par
exemple avec 40% des plastiques des
usages qui proviennent des emballages
c'est une question des choix qui ont été
faits en matière de distribution des
produits c'est une question par exemple
de de présence dans les rayonnages
d'absence par exemple le fait que on
veut que les produits durent plus
longtemps et c'est pour ça qu'ils sont
emballés ils sont emballés par exemple
que on va emballer un concombre qu'on va
emballer un bout de viande dans une
barquette avec un film par dessus mais
ça c'est un choix qui est délibéré parce
que par exemple on veut que les rayons
nages soient plein par exemple un
dimanche soir jusqu'à la fleur de
fermeture bon je prends je parle de
dimanche parce que j'ai mis dans un pays
où les choses sont ouvertes le dimanche
et jusqu'à 22h le dimanche soir tout
doit être plein même si on sait qu'il y
aura un réapprovisionnement le lundi
parce qu'il y a un refus de présenter
des étagères vides et ça ce sont des
choix mais très très simples qui sont
des choix de stratégie commerciale des
choix de rapport de marketing des choix
de rapport à les clientèle
on est arrivé à une sur un emballages un
sur emballage encore un sur emballage
par des choix qui ont été faits en
matière de distribution de la même
manière que ces choix ont été faits on
pourrait faire d'autres choix alors
évidemment ça sera d'autres constantes
peut-être que ça demandera plus de
manutention une manutention qui sera
peut-être plus prudente qui sera
peut-être peut-être
moins directe dans l'accès beaucoup de
choses dans les emballages par exemple
parce que ça permet aux consommateurs
d'aller le prendre donc vous avez un
petit objet et puis vous avez un
emballage plastique qui permet de
l'accrocher sur un croissantoir et ça ce
sont des choses et ce sont des choix des
choix de design des choix de
distribution des choix stratégiques des
choix commerciaux des choix marketing
qui ont été faits
et donc ce sont pas des choses qui
arrivent par hasard après on va arriver
progressivement
aux déchets plastiques et on verrait la
pollution plastique mais de la même
manière lorsque par exemple les
municipalités décident d'installer un
terrain de sport
un terrain par exemple un terrain de
foot en plastique on sait très bien que
ça va mener des déchets plastiques dans
dans les systèmes dans les systèmes de
récupération des eaux et donc c'est un
choix qui est fait et c'est à ce moment
d'ailleurs à mon avis sur ces choix là
qu'il faut être fait on sait on sait que
c'est bout de plastique finissent on
nous a très bien expliqués là dans les
communications donc la question se pose
pourquoi continuer à construire des
terrains de sport en plastique
oui merci je vais donc vous proposer
d'enchaîner avec la deuxième partie de
notre audition publique et la seconde
table ronde la première table ronde a
montré pourquoi un traité international
visant à mettre un terme à la pollution
plastique était indispensable et nous
allons maintenant en questionner les
enjeux scientifiques du traité dans la
France accueille la deuxième réunion de
négociation du 29 mai au 2 juin prochain
le rapport que nous avons remis en
décembre 2020 avec Madame sénatrice
Angèle Préville comportait 49
préconisations dont l'une soutenait le
traité international qui va arriver donc
à Paris prochainement j'avais alors
présenté à l'Assemblée nationale à l'été
2021 une proposition de résolution
invitant la France à soutenir les
initiatives internationales pour mettre
fin à la pollution plastique cette
proposition de résolution avait été
consignée par plus de 400 collectes
députés à adoptés à l'unanimité le 29
novembre 2020 témoignant que tous les
groupes politiques étaient engagés
autour de cette action de lutte contre
la pollution plastique et je me réjouis
donc aujourd'hui que nous puissions
évoquer concrètement ensemble ce traité
international c'était un honneur je
trouve pour la France d'accueillir les
délégations de plus de 160 pays qui
souhaitent faire avancer le sujet la
science est indispensable à l'éclairage
des enjeux du traité qui considèrent le
sujet d'une manière holistique ça a été
rappelé à toutes les étapes du cycle de
vie des plastiques de la production des
granulés industriels jusqu'à la gestion
des objets plastiques devenus des
déchets et cette transversalité intègre
dès lors toutes les formes de pollution
de la plus visible celle des mers et des
rivières des images nous ont été
montrées aux pollutions insidieuses et
invisibles par les micros et
nanoparticules dispersés dans tous les
endroits de la planète mais cette
transversalité rend l'approche du traité
complexe en effet chaque pays est
diversesment concerné par le pollution
plastique en raison de son utilisation
plus ou moins importante en raison de
ces politiques publiques plus ou moins
avancées en raison d'enjeux économiques
différents en raison de la présence ou
non d'infrastructures de gestion des
déchets et en raison du niveau de vie de
ses habitants
ainsi la science à toute sa place dans
l'aide à la décision sur les mesures les
plus adaptées pour concilier conditions
particulières des différents pays
atteindre l'objectif central du traité
celui de la fin de la pollution
plastique en 2030 ainsi pour mieux
appréhender les enjeux scientifiques du
traité international notre premier
intervenant et Monsieur Hugo Maria
Shelly conseiller pour les négociations
internationales à la direction générale
de l'environnement de la Commission
européenne il va nous expliquer la
genèse de ce traité les objectifs
poursuivis mais également la position
des différentes parties prenantes
monsieur Chali vous avez la parole pour
10 minutes et vous êtes en
visioconférence
merci monsieur le Président merci pour
l'invitation de contribuer à cette
position j'espère que vous m'entendez
bien on vous entend très bien très bien
j'ai suivi avec beaucoup d'attention les
échanges dans le palais précédent et je
crois c'est justement il y a beaucoup de
défis qui ont été relevés par rapport à
le réglementation au niveau global que
pourrait être résultat de ces
négociations qui vont continuer à Paris
dans deux semaines et je crois qu'il est
très clair que c'est un processus de
longue date que la problématique de
déchets marins de la police pollution
pour les plastiques figurent à l'ordre
du jour de l'Assemblée internationale de
l'environnement depuis des nombreuses
années et il y a eu des multiples
efforts internationaux et nationaux pour
lutter contre la pollution par le
plastique et juste pour les mentionner
évidemment aussi au sein de l'Union
européenne avec la d'adoption des
stratégies sur la matière plastique si
que les efforts en matière de plastique
à etsage unique d'emballage de déchets
des causes conception des textiles
microplastiques juste pour dire que
l'action de l'Union européenne au niveau
globale et se baser sur une base solide
qui est un acquis très et très pendu
dans le contexte des politiques que je
législations européennes et c'est
accompagné par un renforcement de la
coopération internationale au moyen des
partenariats des projets bilatéraux et
des instruments régionaux alors comment
est-ce que nous sommes arrivés à avoir
cette négociation il faut dire que
c'était une longue rue et depuis 2014
au sein de Linéa il y avait un accord
politique que le maintien du statu quo
n'était pas envisageable et qu'il était
clair que même avec les politiques
initiatives existantes le
des matières plastiques en train de
nauser aussi
à 2040 et je crois que c'était ça qui a
créé une dynamique croissante en faveur
d'une action mondiale le premier essai a
été fait lors de l'univers qu'en 2017
ou quand nous avions une première
épauche de des résolutions qui auraient
au compositeur l'adoption d'un mandat
des négociations mais à ce moment-là ça
échoué parce que des importante
partenaires tels que la Chine les
États-Unis et autres n'étaient pas prêts
pour une telle
décision mais après et jusqu'à la une A5
il y a une dynamique croissante en
faveur d'une action moderne et plus de
140 pays en avant de la univers 5 en
2022 avait appelé un pour le début de
négociation pour un accord mondial sur
le matière plastique et les États
membres de l'Union européenne étaient
largement unis sur la question et
c'était le sujet d'une large
participation des États membres des
ministres des
pour des discussions
en amont de la unie à 5 et qu'est-ce qui
a été important dans ce contexte
l'Union et ses États membres se sont
engagés activement et ont joué un rôle
du premier plan pour réunir de pays
partageant les mêmes valeurs afin de
préparer l'univers et la Commission
européenne a coordonnée faciliter
l'élaboration de résolution phare qui
était présenté par le Pérou et les
Rwanda très important que cette
résolution a été présentée par deux pays
du Sud de l'Amérique latine et du Rwanda
c'est déjà
un précurseur de discussion qu'on a qui
a des approches différentes dans
différentes continents
et il faut dire que
préoccupation qui était dans cette dans
cette action il y avait évidemment
l'action sur la pollution par les
plastiques dans tous les environnements
sans se limiter marin adopter une
perspective de cycle de vie aborder les
problèmes à sa source et pas seulement
en aval
et pas seulement sur une focalisation
sur la gestion des déchets et évidemment
aussi discussion sur le financement et
les ressources financières nécessaires
pour la mise en oeuvre d'un tel accord
il faut dire que de ça il faut vraiment
arriver à
voir que les négociations étaient durs
et c'était vraiment la coalition des
pays ambitieux qui jouer un rôle
déterminant dans l'adoption et la
résolution 114 sur lequel se passe le
mandat de négociations à permis
d'établir un
comité intergouvantable de négociation
qui a commencé ses travaux à Punta
delester Uruguay
en novembre dernier
on a eu un premier échange des positions
et des ambitions entre les différentes
partenaires et je crois qu'il est clair
que on a en principe trois grands
groupes dans ces dans ces négociations
d'un côté il y a la
un groupe de pays à haute ambition qui
regroupe les pays européens les pays
africains une bonne partie les pays de
l'Amérique latine qui appelle pour un
accord les juridiquement contraignant
avec des objectifs et des obligations
juridiquement contenantes pour tous les
partis
adoptant une approche cycle de vie
c'est-à-dire avec des obligations et des
objectifs concernant la production
la conception
l'utilisation la distribution et la
gestion des déchets ainsi que la
utilisation des produits des matières
recyclées il y a un deuxième groupe qui
regroupe en partie des pays ambitieux
qui veulent quand même un certain focus
sur la question geste de déchets couplés
à la à des règles ou à des objectifs et
des
engagements par rapport à la ce qu'on
appelle le Legacy plastique c'est à dire
la pollution existante et de élimination
de la pollution existante il y a un
troisième groupe qui va jouer
rôle déterminant qui est le groupe de
pays qui sont dépendants de la
des produits fossiles et qui ont ces
dernières années grandement
augmenté leur capacité de protection et
là je parle évidemment des pays du Golfe
et des pays tels que l'Arabie Saoudite
Saoudite
les Émirats les Émirats arabes unis et
autres qui ont clairement fait entendre
que ils étaient pas confortables avec
l'idée d'un accord qui aurait pour but
de limiter la production et la
consommation de plastique en tant que
tel il y a un
autre problème dans ce contexte qui a
les États-Unis qui en principe sont en
faveur d'un accord juridiquement
contraignant mais dû à leur
contrainte constitutionnelle le du Sénat
qui est dans la approbation des accords
internationaux voudraient un accord type
Paris c'est à dire sans des engagements
juridiquement contraignants pour les
parties ou tous les actions et tous les
des engagements seraient volontaires
mais compris dans un plan d'action
nationale
un petit peu comme on connaît de dans le
sphère de climat les contributions
nationalement déterminés évidemment il y
a un grand débat sur la mise en la mise
en oeuvre et la nécessité des la
génération de ressources financières
pour la mise en oeuvre surtout dans des
pays on voit de développement et là
évidemment il y a une question de qui on
sera responsable et là il y a une grande
différence à des discussions telles que
au climat au leadersité lorsqu'on
regarde le
volume de production au niveau global il
faut dire que une bonne partie ou je
veux dire la majorité de la production
maintenant et dans des pays soi-disant
du Sud du sud alors que à ce moment-là
pour en application du principe
pollueur-payeur il faudrait prévoir que
les pays qui sont les producteurs du
plastique ou le producteur des produits
plastiques
prennent leur part dans la financement
de cette mise en oeuvre de cet accord
tout cela sera soumis à un premier
discussion lors de la réunion de Paris
cela base de cette discussion était un
papier qui a été élaboré sur la dépasse
des discussions à la première réunion en
novembre dernier qui maintenant présente
tous les options pour les éléments d'un
tel traité et les États membres de des
Nations Unies seront appelées de se
prononcer sur les différentes options
qui sont soumis à discussion
l'étape a préparé sera la préparation
d'un d'un premier draft d'après ma
croquis de cette traité qui sera ensuite
discuter lors de la troisième réunion
d'une comité qui aura lieu en novembre
en Nairobi au Kenya on a pour but de
conclure négociation fin 2004 on a
encore deux réunions du comité de
négociation en 2024 avec le but d'une
conférence diplomatique
en Équateur en printemps 2025 où nous
espérons avoir un traité ambitieux et
traitant de tous ces sujets pour
soumettre à la approbation de tous les
parties et tous les États membres de
Nations Unies voilà je me le mythe je
suis certainement disponible pour
répondre à tes questions des
intervenants merci beaucoup
je vous je vous remercie pour Monsieur
Chali pour votre présentation précise et
synthétique et qui tenait le temps
imparti au niveau de la prise de parole
un autre deuxième intervenantes et
Madame Véronique Guérin professeur de
physiologie à l'école nationale
vétérinaire de Toulouse et membre de
l'unité mixte de recherche toxalim afin
de mettre fin à la pollution plastique
certains pays souhaitent stopper la
production et l'utilisation de certains
polymères et produits chimiques dans la
liste serait fixés dans une annexe ce
pose alors la question la définition des
critères pour identifier les polymères
et les produits chimiques à mettre dans
la dite annexe parmi les critères
suggérés figurent leur dangerosité pour
l'environnement ou la santé humaine en
effet les matières plastiques sont une
source importante de substance chimiques
nous l'avons vu lors de la première
table ronde et en particulier de
perturbateurs endocriniens comme
leftalat les bifenols ou les substances
perfluoraux alkylées des études menées
dans le monde entier ont documenté
l'exposition généralisée aux
perturbateurs endocriniens utilisés dans
les matières plastiques et leur
contribution à l'infertilité au mode
maladie non transmissible comme le
baisés le diabète de type 2 les maladies
cardiovasculaires et certains cancers la
législation européenne est considérée
comme très protectrice vis-à-vis des
consommateurs et pourrait servir de
modèles pourtant l'exemple du bifignol a
excusez-moi montre les limites de la
réglementation européenne et les
difficultés d'interdire des substances
pourtant connues pour leur dangerosité
madame Guérard vous avez la parole
également pour 10 minutes
merci pour cette introduction et pour
votre invitation alors avant de décider
de répondre à cette question je vais
présenter quelques éléments de contexte
donc
[Musique]
diapositivesment utilisé pour produire
des polymères donc c'est un assemblage
de bispinola en longue chaîne et c'est
polymère donc rentre à la composition
des polycarbonate qui sont à la base
donc dans des plastiques qui sont durs
transparents qui sont des bonnes
alternatives au vert mais également dans
les résines époxy phénoliques donc là le
bispinola sert surtout dans ses résines
à comme par exemple des revêtements
internes des boîtes métalliques alors il
faut savoir que moins de 5% du biscuit
Nola et en fait utiliser comme onomer
additif à des plastiques de type PVC
additif à papier thermique pour
réveiller l'encre mais aussi pour
produire d'autres produits chimiques
comme par exemple des retardateurs de
flammes qui sont ajoutés au mobilier
alors normalement à moins comme on l'a
vu comme on dit mes collègues que les
polymères soient fragmentés en micro
nanoplastiques en fait des polymères ils
sont pas considérés comme dangereux
pourquoi parce qu'ils peuvent pas
rentrer dans l'organisme par contre dans
le cas des polymères de bisphénolA on
peut avoir d'abord on a une
polymérisation qui n'est pas complète et
hydrolyse qui peut se produire et qui va
libérer progressivement du bicynola dans
les aliments dans les boissons et ceci
de façon plus importante lorsqu'on est
en présence par exemple de détergent
qu'on chauffe ou lorsque le plastique
usé et c'est ce qui est à l'origine de
la image très choquante du du biberon
polycarbonate donc il est chauffé au
micro-ondes etc
diapositive suivante
il y a un rapport de l'Agence européenne
des produits chimiques donc qui a montré
donc là évaluer la production de
bisphénolA dans le monde elle est
actuellement en 2019 elle était de 7
millions de tonnes un petit peu plus et
globalement en fait il y a production
les besoins en bispinola va augmenter au
cours du temps alors si on s'intéresse
maintenant aux émissions dans
l'environnement le graphique de droite
montre les concentrations moyennes de
bispinola dans les eaux de surface
européenne
on peut voir qu'il y a quand même une
tendance à une diminution à partir de
2012 peut-être en raison des mesures de
restriction mais globalement l'agence
constate que en 2020 il y en a toujours
donc le pisser dans la est toujours émis
et que même si la contribution de chaque
utilisation individuelle est faible
globalement la totalité de toutes les
utilisations conduit à une situation
qu'elle le juge inacceptable
un diapositive suivante
nous sommes tous exposés au bisphénolA
en fait exposition elle est d'abord
orale elle est liée à la contamination
des aliments donc des gestions
d'aliments et de boissons contaminés par
du bispinola qui relargué
faut savoir que tous les biscuits dans
la qu'on ingère rentre dans l'organisme
parce que l'absorption est très efficace
heureusement là est aussi très
rapidement éliminé de l'organisme dans
les urines et c'est pour ça que la
quantité de bisphénol qui est dans les
urines en osines c'est vraiment un
marqueur de la quantité qui rentrait
dans l'organisme
alors qu'en est-il de la population donc
qui a une étude Esteban qui étude
française qui a été réalisée entre 2014
et 2016 elle a évalué donc
l'imprégnation de la population
française au bisminola 1900 adultes et
500 en France ce qui a été montré c'est
qu'on retrouve du bispinola un total des
échantillons d'urine donc si on peut
aussi vous donner vos urines on
retrouverait c'est tout le monde du
bisphénolA alors comme ce comme ce
bisphénol est éliminé très rapidement ça
veut dire qu'en fait l'exposition elle
est pas permanente mais elle est au
moins quotidienne et à partir de cette
étude donc les auteurs ont évalué la
quantité moyenne de bisphénols qu'on
absorbe quotidiennement alors elle
paraît faible elle est de 0,005
microgrammes par kilogramme de poids
corporel et par jour alors jusqu'à
présent la considérer que c'était une
quantité qui était sans risque parce
qu'elle était trop faible pour présenter
un danger
mais dans sa récente évaluation l'Agence
européenne de sécurité des aliments donc
lève ça a abaisser très fortement ce
qu'on appelle la dose journalière
admissible c'est-à-dire la quantité
qu'on peut ingérer quotidiennement sans
danger pour la santé toute sa vie et
maintenant en fait là on regarde la
quantité moyenne qu'on absorbe
quotidiennement finalement elle est 100
fois supérieure à cette nouvelle dose
sans danger ce qui a amené les sac à
conclure que l'exposition humaine au
bisphénolA a été préoccupante
diapositive suivante
alors ces résultats la question sur
l'origine de ce bisphénol puisqu'on sait
qu'il y a eu beaucoup de restrictions et
comme en tant que scientifique en fait
travaillant sur les effets du bispinola
je me suis demandé d'où venait cette
qualité l'origine c'était exposition et
est-ce que la réglementation qui n'a pas
été suffisante alors le bispinola comme
tous les produits chimiques relèvent du
règlement européen riches donc riche et
l'acronyme de enregistrement évaluation
autorisation et restriction
donc selon ce règlement tous les
fabricants ou les importateurs de
substances chimiques à hauteur de plus
d'une tonne par an doivent enregistrer
ces substances ils doivent en fait
identifier les risques et transmettre
leur dossier à l'Agence européenne de
sécurité l'Agence européenne des
produits chimiques qui va vérifier leur
conformité et selon le risque s'il y a
un risque donc il y a un plan d'action
communautaire le Cora qui va demander
aux États membres de lieu notamment
d'évaluer cette substance et à ce moment
là il peut y avoir donc une proposition
de classification de cette substance
dans la règlement CLP c'est-à-dire pour
le classification étiquetage et
emballage donc l'inclusion dans l'annexe
6 de cette réglementation permettra
d'identifier de montrer vraiment aux
utilisateurs quels sont les dangers
si cette substance est soit cancérigène
mutagène persistante ou perturbateurs
endocriniens elle peut être identifiée
comme substance très préoccupante une
substance en voi concerne schc dans ce
cas-là sur inscrit dans une liste
d'autorisation de l'annexe 14 du
règlement et à ce moment-là ne sera pas
interdite mais elle sera soumise son
utilisation sera soumise à autorisation
en fait il était un membre sont équipés
peuvent aussi proposer des restrictions
particulières
enfin la France a souhaité donc proposer
une restriction donc qui est maintenant
en œuvre depuis 2015 c'est une
restriction de la teneur en bispinante
dans les papiers thermiques voilà
l'Allemagne en cours de en train de
déposer notre d'autres restrictions
diapositive suivante alors question
finalement les qu'est-ce qu'on peut voir
comme limite de la réglementation
d'abord les polymères en fait sont
exemptés de la réglementation puisqu'ils
ont exécuté de l'enregistrement et de
l'évaluation dans le cas du règlement
pourquoi parce que les donc ça veut dire
qu'en fait la majorité vous avez vu que
la majeure partie du bispinola n'est pas
concernée par cette réglementation de
fait c'est moins de 5%. une même des
substances qui sera importées en France
ou fabriquées en France et qui seraient
destinés être utilisé pour être
polymérisé pour dire des polymères ne
sont pas concernés par l'autorisation il
y a pas besoin d'autorisation dans ce
cas là
la diapositive suivante
en fait l'argumentation riche elle
paraît en contradiction qu'un autre
règlement qui règle en fait la les
substances qui peuvent entrer dans la
composition des matériaux en matière
plastique destinées en contact avec les
dents alimentaires donc c'est un autre
règlement européen qui va lister des
substances autorisées pour la
fabrication de ce matériaux donc le
bispinola fait partie de cette liste et
donc il est autorisé à être utilisé et
sur comme polymère avec une limite de
migration spécifique qui a été fixée en
2015 à 0,05 mg par kg d'aliments
diapositive suivante alors une autre
limite la réglementation en fait c'est
que reach la procédure d'autorisation
elle a pour objectif quand même de
remplacer des substances dangereuses par
d'autres substances ou technologies
moins dangereuses c'est la raison pour
laquelle très précocement en fait les
industriels ont remplacé le bisphénolA
par d'autres bispinoles donc
majoritairement le bistinoles en
particulier dans les papiers thermiques
et actuellement le bistinoles c'est
identifié comme potentiellement donc un
SVHC donc une substance très
préoccupante et donc il devrait
prochainement il pourrait prochainement
rentrer dans l'annexe donc 14 donc être
soumis à régulation
dans notre dans notre équipe a montré en
plus il y a en 2019 a publié une étude
qui montrait que le bisphénolès est plus
persistant dans l'organisme que le
bispinola donc clairement dans ce cas là
on est face à une substitution tout à
fait regrettable
diapositive suivante enfin limite de la
réglementation c'est que la
réglementation REACH elle évalue un seul
composé à la fois donc déjà c'est ça
prend beaucoup de temps et à évaluer les
composés de façon individuelle et les
toxicologues en fait sont
estimes que cette évaluation elle est
suffisante parce que d'abord on est
exposé à de multiples composés midi et
des milliers de composés et on sait que
combinés même afin de dos certaines
molécules va avoir leur effet nocifs non
seulement s'additionner de fait mais
aussi se renforcer ou simplifier c'est
ce qu'on appelle l'effet cocktail et
l'évaluation des risques associés aux
effets cocktails c'est vraiment un enjeu
scientifique un enjeu de santé publique
qu'elle pourra répondre
diapositive suivante alors je vais juste
terminer justement par rapport aux
effets cocktails en présentant les
résultats d'une étude qui est paru
l'année dernière dans Science qui a
identifié en fait un cocktail de
polluants du quotidien qui aurait des
effets déléternes la construction du
cerveau des jeunes enfants en fait une
étude qui a été basée sur une courte
suédoise mère-enfant et donc là on voit
ici le cocktail de substances qui a été
associé à un retard dans l'acquisition
de langage chez des enfants de 2 ans et
dans ce cocktail on retrouve comme
d'habitude biscuit Nola mais aussi
d'autres d'autres substances dérivés du
plastique donc des talates des
plastiques mais aussi des pie face donc
qui sont en fait qui interviennent pour
produire des primaires donc l'étude
concluée que les enfants qui étaient nés
des femmes les plus exposées les 10% des
femmes les plus exposées avaient un
risque trois fois plus important d'avoir
un retard dans l'acquisition du langage
que les femmes les moins exposées
je vous remercie
c'est mon tour de plus et moi j'avais
coupé le micro c'est à mon tour de vous
remercier Madame Guérard notre troisième
intervenante et Madame Nathalie Gontard
directrice de recherche l'inrae le futur
traité international a vocation à
prendre des dispositions pour augmenter
la circularité des plastiques dans
l'économie afin de réduire la production
de plastique vierge c'est égard le
recyclage est imposé comme la solution
censée permettre la circularité des
plastiques dans les pays développés des
investissements considérables ont été
consentis par les pouvoirs publics pour
mettre en place des systèmes de collecte
et de tri de plus en plus performants
tandis que le recyclage chimique est
présenté comme la solution pouvant
parvenir enfin à recyclage infini des
plastiques qu'en est-il en réalité je
laisse la parole à Madame Gontard pour
nous évoquer le sujet du recyclage ses
atouts et ses limites vous avez la
parole pour 10 minutes
ok merci merci pour l'invitation aussi
donc je ne vais pas vous présenter
les activités de recherche de mon
laboratoire mais plutôt les conclusions
ou du moins
un décryptage en tout cas de ce que nous
avons compris des différentes stratégies
et des efforts pour essayer de le
comprendre donc je vais vous parler
d'empreinte plastique de des cyclage et
d'économie tire-bouchon ça changera un
petit peu de l'économie circulaire et de
prévention à la source donc on en a déjà
parlé la fermeture de ce fameux robinet
alors diapo suivante voilà donc ça on a
bien vu on a eu des vraiment des super
explications très très à jour sur le
fait que le plastique est un matériau
qui dure très longtemps le plastique
c'est vraiment typiquement ce qu'on
appelle s'inscrit en tout cas
typiquement dans ce qu'on appelle une
économie linéaire avec un épuisement des
ressources et puis dans ce cas là un
comportement très particulier qui est
très différent de tout j'existe bien
tous les matériaux que l'homme
utilise
l'humain on va dire l'homme et la femme
bien sûr avec une accumulation dans tous
les compartiments de notre environnement
voilà on a une durée de vie très très
élevée mais ça je vais parvenir dessus
une fragmentation une sorption de
polluants n'a pas beaucoup parlé mais
c'est quand même quelque chose
d'important une diffusion d'un autre
écosystème et une trace une
translocation possible dans les organes
des êtres vivants voilà pourquoi on en
retrouve un petit peu partout
diapositive suivante voilà donc économie
linéaire donc je pense qu'il faut faire
attention déjà au niveau des termes de
pas parler de cycle de vie pour le
plastique mais plutôt de chaîne de vie
puisque jusqu'à nouvel ordre le
plastique
en tout cas ça ça vie ne constitue pas
un cycle donc on a quatre grandes étapes
l'élaboration l'usage vous le savez tous
l'usage on en a parlé c'est un moteur
pour l'utilisation de ce plastique
le post-usage qui consiste à
essentiellement gérer les déçus donc
entre autres avec des actions notamment
de recyclage et puis surtout une
quatrième et dernière étape qui est
celle justement qui nous inquiète le
plus qui s'est révélé de façon un petit
peu plus récente qui est sa fin de vie
et son vieillissement sur le long terme
avec ce fameux réservoir de micro et de
nanoplastiques que nous sommes en train
de constituer c'est-à-dire que tous les
plastiques que nous n'avons pas détruit
moléculairement vont forcément vieillir
sur un temps plus ou moins long pour
venir grossir se réservoir qui entre qui
a déjà commencé à diffuser un petit peu
partout alors je veux pas revenir sur le
cette idée d'usage unique qui est enfin
en tout cas ces matériaux jetables c'est
vrai que c'est regrettable mais je
voudrais quand même dire qu'il n'y a pas
que les matériaux qui sont jetés ou qui
ont une durée d'usage très courte qui
sont dangereux et qui produisent des
micro plastique tous les tous les
plastiques vieillissent que ce soit
après leur usage c'est à dire en tant
que déchet par exemple lorsqu'ils sont
mis dans des stations d'enfouissement
ou pendant leur visage c'est à dire que
les plastiques par exemple qu'on utilise
dans les bâtiments durent très longtemps
et pourtant ils vieillissent et pourtant
il libère des micro-ondesoplastiques et
et ce sont ces micro-innoplastiques que
l'on retrouve aux côtés d'autres
micro-henanoplastiques au fin fond des
glaces de l'Arctique par exemple voilà
donc ça c'est important prochain diapo
on a bien parlé aussi de nos limites de
connaissances et actuellement donc les
limites de connaissance elle elle
connaît à peu près bien les émissions en
tout cas ce qui se passe et les
conséquences de ce plastique sur une
durée assez longue donc vous avez là en
horizontal la durée de vie du plastique
enfin des plastiques on va dire on a des
outils des pour évaluation pour évaluer
l'impact environnemental qu'on appelle
des ACV des analyses de cycle de vie
et qui nous permettent d'évaluer
l'empreinte carbone d'un procédé d'un
matériel etc sauf que les connaissances
actuelles ne nous permettent pas de
quantifier les impacts des plastiques et
notamment donc de ces micros et de ses
nanoplastiques et donc du coup le
principal danger lié au plastique et qui
est sa persistance sa fragmentation etc
n'est pas comptabilisé dans les ACV or
actuellement la grande majorité des
raisonnements sont basés sur des
empreintes carbones du plastique qui
viennent des ACV alors c'est pas par
mauvaise volonté c'est juste que l'on ne
dispose pas des connaissances
nécessaires pour quantifier ses effets
pourtant ces effets on le sait ils sont
là ils sont assez effrayants mais on ne
les comptabilise pas donc du coup tout
ce qui se passe sur le très long terme
avec une accumulation dans l'Atmos dans
tous les compartiments donc dans
l'atmosphère la biosphère l'hydrosphère
et y compris donc les sols constituent
ce qu'on appelle une empreinte plastique
et actuellement il y a pas mal de
scientifiques qui se battent pour faire
reconnaître cette empreinte plastique et
pour dire attention on ne peut pas
établir des raisonnements en ce qui
concerne les matériaux plastiques sur
une empreinte carbone et sur une ACV
parce que on oublie le principal danger
voilà ça c'est important et ensuite
prochaine diapos voilà alors du coup les
solutions on parle d'une économie
linéaire donc avec ces problèmes
d'empreintes plastiques alors au départ
c'est des macros déchets puis après
c'est des micros déchets puis après ça
devient des nano déchets on sait pas
tout on sait pas sur combien de temps on
sait quand même on sait on sait qui sont
là ces déchets mais on sait pas
exactement parce que c'est très très
compliqué voilà donc on essaie de
trouver des solutions et on a construit
un espèce de je dirais de
oui de concepts autour de l'économie
circulaire l'économie circulaire le plus
bel exemple d'économie circulaire qui
nous est offert c'est la nature qui qui
nous l'offre avec toutes les matières
organiques avec ces matières organiques
qui sont biodégradées puis ensuite
régénéré par photo synthèse à
l'identique c'est la feuille d'arbre que
vous retrouvez que vous avez au
printemps qui tombent et qui ensuite
régénéral identique etc donc on a
construit ce concept
et notamment la Stratégie Europe qui a
été
orienté essentiellement focalisé sur le
recyclage et qui nous dit ben voilà on
va mettre en place une économie
circulaire et on va recycler
c'est-à-dire qu'on va régénérer à
l'identique
une bouteille en plastique après usage
elle va redevenir une même bouteille en
plastique et puis comme ça on aura plus
d'idées des déchets puis on aura plus de
d'épuisement des ressources et puis on
aura plus d'empreintes plastiques puis
tout va bien alors on nous rencontre
encore de l'empreinte carbone mais bon
disons que quand même le principal
danger sera écarté
diapo suivante
voilà alors ce qu'on sait faire le mieux
c'est en termes d'économie en termes de
recyclage donc on l'a là il vient d'être
ajoutée c'est le recyclage des
bouteilles en PET que l'on broie que
l'on nettoie que l'on décontamine parce
qu'il y a des aspects des histoires de
sécurité parce que le plastique n'est
pas un matériau inerte contrairement
ouvert au métaux etc il y a des il y a
des absorptions de polluants on les
décontamine et on peut refabriquer une
bouteille alors le plastique se dégrade
c'est très compliqué il faut contrôler
la chaîne d'approvisionnement bon je
vais pas rentrer dans le détail c'est
quelque chose de très limité on ne peut
l'appliquer que pour les bouteilles en
PET qui ne représentent qu'un 2% des
plastiques on peut appliquer ça sur deux
trois cycles ça permet de diminuer quand
même la consommation de plastique Vierge
et de déchets mais ça reste extrêmement
limité l'impact sur l'empreinte
plastique est très limité
et donc du coup dans cette emballement
pour l'économie circulaire et le
recyclage diapo d'après on est parti sur
ben on va recycler mais pas tout à fait
en fait on va descycler et donc
actuellement ce qu'on appelle recyclage
c'est essentiellement du dessyclage
c'est à dire qu'on ne retransforme pas
la bouteille en bouteille la barquette
embarquette on va retransformer en un
autre objet qui va avoir trouvé une
certaine utilité donc on va chercher des
débouchés donc c'est typiquement par
exemple la bouteille qu'on va
transformer en pull la barquette qu'on
va transformer en brique de construction
ou en meuble pour remplacer le bois ou
en ou en pot de fleur en terre cuite
donc pour remplacer la terre cuite etc
donc ça c'est du des cyclage
diapo d'après
et voilà et donc cette économie du des
cyclage le problème c'est qu'elle ne
contribue absolument pas à réduire la
pollution plastique parce que tous ces
nouveaux objets qui vont remplacer des
matériaux qui ne posaient pas de
problème environnementaux majeurs comme
le plastique comme la laine comme le
bois comme la terre cuite etc ils vont
continuer à se dégrader ce pull que vous
aurez acheté en polyester recyclé vous
allez laver il va libérer et ensuite une
fois des fibres et une fois que vous en
aurez marre vous allez le jeter et il va
continuer à se dégrader cette chaise en
plastique recyclée elle va continuer à
se dégrader en micro et en unoplastiques
donc on ne fait absolument pas on ne
réduit absolument pas la contribution à
l'empreinte plastique
et pour moi c'est encore plus grave
parce qu'on se crée une dépendance aux
déchets plastiques c'est-à-dire qu'on
construit des filières entières sauf
qu'après il faut les alimenter on se
crée une double dépendance aussi parce
qu'en fait disparaître des filières
entières de matériaux locaux
traditionnels qui ne posaient pas de
problème actuellement la filière de la
laine en souffre beaucoup la laine ne
vaut plus rien elle est mise à dégrader
dans des dans des endroits bon bref et
parce que c'est un matériau
biodégradable bien sûr
et donc du coup finalement on se demande
quel est l'intérêt de ce de cette
économie du des cyclage sauf que voilà
il y a une grosse confusion et ce qu'on
appelle des cyclages et bien ce qu'on
appelle recyclage en fait c'est du
cyclage la preuve en est c'est que
certains pays aux affichez des taux de
recyclage de 50 % comme l'Autriche et
l'Allemagne que l'on cite en exemple
sauf que s'il recycle les 50% de leur
plastique ils auraient pu diminuer ils
auraient dû diminuer par deux tout
simplement leur consommation de
plastique bien sauf qu'elle n'a même pas
commencé à diminuer elle continue à
augmenter donc si ça c'est pas une
preuve ben je sais pas je sais pas ce
qu'il nous faut voilà donc attention à
ces discours qui n'ont pas de prise avec
la réalité qui ne sont pas ancrées dans
la réalité des choses et là actuellement
je trouve qu'on assiste un petit peu à
cette espèce de décollage où on
construit des concepts qui n'ont pas de
prise avec la réalité alors je dis pas
qu'il faut pas les construire je dis
juste que on peux pas on peut pas
construire des concepts si on n'a pas
non plus les bases les principes de base
que la matière que la réalité de la
matière doit respecter
diapo suivante voilà donc du coup le
résultat c'est un exemple de résultat
voilà où on en est là c'est juste un
bilan d'après les chiffres de plastique
Europe sur les emballages plastiques
uniquement et en Europe bref donc si on
fait le bilan on en a à peu près 34% qui
sont incinérés donc là pour le coup pas
d'empreinte plastique mais on contribue
à l'empreinte carbone on en a 16% qui
sont enfoui donc l'enfouissement c'est
un grand trou avec avec un géotextile en
plastique et qui va se dégrader au même
rythme que les plastiques qu'il contient
et donc ça contribue au réservoir un
jour ou l'autre c'est plastique se
retrouveront sous forme de particules
plastique certes c'est pas nous qui
allons souffrir ce sont les générations
à venir mais bon voilà ensuite on en a à
peu près 10% qui ne sont pas répertoriés
donc forcément
imaginez qu'ils vont grossir se
réservoir et puis la grande majorité 32%
qui sont déciclées en boucs donc qui
vont servir à la production d'autres
matériaux donc alors moi j'ai mis 5% de
recyclage en boucle fermée là j'ai été
très très optimiste les chiffres étant
pas très précis ni très cohérent j'ai
mis le maximum voilà voilà où on en est
bon toujours éthique actuellement sur
les plastiques que nous utilisons il y a
60% de ces plastiques qui viennent
grossir le réservoir de micro et des
nanoplastiques que nous sommes en train
de constituer pour les générations à
venir d'où je pense que le terme de
bombes à retardement n'est pas n'est pas
exagéré voilà
dernière diapo
alors peut-être juste je vais terminer
sur celle-là juste pour dire qu'en fait
on a vraiment tout tout on a ciblé le
déchet on s'est focalisé là-dessus du
coup on est parti sur des narratifs des
commissaires et qui ne fonctionnent pas
ce que je voudrais dire aussi c'est que
le fait que cette empreinte plastique ne
soit pas prise en compte elle est encore
en train de générer des des effets
secondaires notamment dans tous les
efforts qui sont faits en termes de
transition qu'elles soient numérique et
qu'elle soit
et qu'elle soit agroécologique qu'elle
soit énergétique où là on assiste au
développement de solutions
technologiques qui cherchent à se
libérer de l'empreinte carbone en
s'engourant dans l'empreinte plastique
mais mais sans le comptabiliser donc
quand on quand on quand on réduit
l'utilisation de pesticides le
la rosace forcément on le fait avec
l'utilisation de matériaux plastiques
quand on les énergies vertes c'est
pareil enfin bref bon voilà donc tout ça
c'est important après dernière diapo
voilà alors les solutions ben je pense
qu'il est important que l'on sorte de
notre Déni c'est à dire que toutes les
solutions technologiques que nous sommes
en train de développer et Dieu sait que
j'y travaille dessus depuis plus de 30
ans puisque c'est
sur ces solutions que j'ai investi toute
ma vie professionnelle j'ai construit
des gros projets d'élabos etc donc on
travaille sur le recyclage on travaille
sur le développement biodégradable on se
travaille sur la réduction de
l'utilisation de ces plastiques dans les
secteurs de l'agriculture et de
l'agroalimentaire mais il faut quand
même être bien lucide et savoir que même
en mettant tout bout à bout toutes ces
solutions on n'arrivera jamais à couvrir
qu'une infime partie de l'inondation
plastique que nous cherchons à éponger
donc ces solutions continuons à y
travailler dessus bien évidemment c'est
ce que je fais mais par contre le combat
doit maintenant avoir lieu en amont et
j'espère que ce traité soit disant
contraignant sera en mesure de mener ce
combat en amont c'est à dire qu'on doit
réduire notre consommation on ne fermera
pas le robinet parce que le plastique
est un matériau quand même qui nous a
apporté des progrès mais il faut bien
reconnaître que les trois quarts des
plastiques qu'on nous utilise que l'on
utilise actuellement en comble ils
encombrent notre vie ils nous mettent en
danger et il faut absolument réduire
cette consommation et pour cela il ne
faut pas nous détourner enfin détourner
notre attention et nos moyens vers des
solutions qui n'en sont pas du genre les
filtres à la sortie des des machines à
laver ok c'est très bien mais pourquoi
on n'arrête pas tout simplement où on
diminue pas notre consommation de de
vêtements fibres synthétiques il
suffirait de nous informer comment vous
faites pour savoir ne serait-ce pour
savoir ce que ce que vous achetez est en
fibres synthétique c'est quasiment
impossible les étiquettes c'est très
compliqué donc voilà et puis il y a des
tas de de voilà du des cyclage qui n'en
est pas les les toutes les actions pour
récupérer c'est bien d'aller récupérer
le plastique dans les océans mais le
problème c'est qu'il faut c'est qu'il
faut mener justement ce combat en amont
alors moi il y a une autre aussi mesure
qui me semble importante c'est
d'interdire les mouvements
transfrontaliers de déchets plastiques
et aussi pour nous éviter de penser
qu'il suffit d'éduquer les pays du Sud
pour qu'il n'y ait plus de problèmes
dans ces pays-là je voudrais vous
rappeler quand même que la consommation
de plastique est parfaitement corrélée
au PIB d'un pays et que donc plus nous
sommes riches et plus notre empreinte
plastique est élevée et que la grande
majorité de ces déchets partent ailleurs
et que lorsqu'on les voit ensuite il
faut savoir que en grande partie ce sont
nos déchets que l'on voit donc je pense
que les déchets comme le plastique ne
devrait pas avoir le droit de passer des
frontières si on les a utilisés c'est à
nous de les gérer on peut pas demander à
des pays de gérer des matériaux que
nous-mêmes nous ne sommes pas en mesure
de gérer voilà ça c'est important
informer le citoyen
ça aussi très important qu'on ait les
moyens de savoir où se situe ce
plastique et puis bien entendu tout ne
peut pas reposer sur les épaules du
consommateur il faut encourager tous les
secteurs industriels à se poser la
question de la réduction de leur
empreinte plastique et donc de
l'utilisation du plastique et cette
question n'a pas encore été posée voilà
merci
merci Madame madame Gontard
notre quatrième intervenant et Monsieur
Olivier Gabus professeur associé en
sa Centrale Lille à l'Institut Centrale
Lille en charge des matières
éco-responsables pour le groupe Legrand
l'augmentation de la circularité des
plastiques dans l'économie des sites de
revoir leurs conception afin de garantir
leur recyclabilité mais également
d'imposer l'intégration de matière
plastique recyclée dans les nouveaux
produits c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'éco-conception toutefois il semble que
la définition de ce principe des
co-consception soit beaucoup plus large
que ce qu'on peut imaginer au départ par
ailleurs l'incorporation de plastique
recyclé n'est pas sans poser d'autres
problèmes le retour d'expérience d'un
groupe comme le grand va nous permettre
de mesurer les opportunités mais
également les enjeux de l'éco-conception
monsieur Gabus vous avez la parole et
vous êtes en visioconférence merci
monsieur le Président bonjour à toutes
et à tous alors effectivement je précise
une chose c'est que je vais intervenir
avec une double casquette puisque
effectivement je suis salarié du groupe
Laurent
au sein duquel je
développe l'utilisation des matières
plastiques et travailler et travaille
depuis quelques années maintenant sur le
recyclage des matières plastiques et
cette activité là chez le grand est
associée à une activité au sein de
l'École Centrale de Lille où j'ai occupe
le rôle d'enseignants associés voilà
alors la diapositive suivante s'il vous
plaît
voilà alors le groupe le Grand en fait
est une société française qui fabrique
des équipements électriques et
électrotechniques
de différentes catégories de différents
domaines qui est localisés à Limoges en
France et avec la diapositive suivante
s'il vous plaît c'est donc une société
qui est largement spécialisé dans la
transformation de matériaux donc des
matériaux métalliques et des matériaux
plastiques à partir desquels on va
construire des sous-ensemble qui en
étant assemblées vont finir par arriver
à l'état de produits finis qui
deviendront donc des composants
électriques électrotechniques qui seront
donc des produits finis commercialisés
donc l'activité de Laurent est
essentiellement une activité de
transformation de matériaux métalliques
et plastique
alors
depuis quelques années maintenant le
grand est fortement orienté vers
l'incorporation de matières plastiques
recyclée dans ces produits alors pour un
clin d'oeil à madame comptard je pense
qu'on peut réellement parler de
recyclage parce que à chaque fois qu'on
a intégré la matière plastique dans des
composants c'est des composants qui
initialement été déjà fabriqués en
plastique donc nous n'avons pas déplacé
du bois ou des matériaux classiques par
de la matière plastique et donc
aujourd'hui nous avons différentes
sources et différentes origines de
matériaux recyclés qui nous permettent
de fabriquer différents composants qui
sont intégrés dans des produits finis
qui sont donc porteurs d'une certaine
quantité de matière plastique recyclées
et aujourd'hui nous consommons à peu
près 5000 tonnes de matière plastique
recyclée avec l'objectif d'amener cette
quantité là à 8000 tonnes d'ici 204
voilà pour les éléments de contexte en
lien avec le grand et moi très
clairement je travaille depuis 7 à 8 ans
sur le développement et le déploiement
de l'utilisation de ces matières
plastiques recyclées dans le groupe
alors on parle généralement
d'écoconception et la question qui est
soumis aujourd'hui c'est comment est-ce
que les co-consception peut être quelque
chose qui peut aider à l'incorporation
de matières plastiques recyclée alors
puisqu'on parle des co-conceptions il
m'a paru important dans redéfinir un
certain nombre de principes et en fait
l'éco-conception c'est juste une
démarche qui va consister à intégrer des
considérations environnementales dès la
conception d'un produit d'un bien ou
d'un service et surtout de maintenir ses
considérations environnementales tout au
long de la phase de fabrication et
d'utilisation alors généralement qui dit
éco-conception dit analyse de cycle de
vie on en a déjà entendu parler
l'Analyse de Cycle de Vie étant une
approche à travers de laquelle et bien
on va considérer qu'un produit
finalement né et finit par mourir avec
des différentes étapes qui vont ponctuer
sa vie donc il est étape où le produit
est encore à l'état de matériaux brut il
est fabriqué il est distribué utilisé il
arrive en fin de vie et on va essayer de
modéliser ou d'estimer l'ensemble des
impacts environnementaux portés par ces
différentes étapes et ceci donc au
travers de différents indicateurs
environnementaux
alors la diapositive suivante nous
montre quelques exemples d'indicateurs
environnementaux qui seront donc tous
plus ou moins en lien avec des impacts
environnementaux donc on pourra
considérer par exemple l'épuisement de
ressources naturelles on pourra
considérer la consommation énergétique
on pourra consommer considéré pardon les
consommations en eau on pourra
considérer les impacts sur le
réchauffement climatique au travers du
Global warning donc on a à disposition
tout un tas d'indicateurs
environnementaux qui vont donc pouvoir
être prises en compte dans la
modélisation de type ACV
la diapositive suivante s'il vous plaît
donc l'Analyse de Cycle de Vie considère
consiste à donc à croiser pour chacune
des étapes du bien ou du produit
considéré et bien la modélisation ou
l'estimation de la valeur d'un impact
pour que par une forme de cumul on
puisse arriver à un total qui nous
donnera finalement l'analyse de cycle de
vie du produit
au global
alors
un produit éco-conçu selon la CV c'est
très simple à partir du moment où vous
avez une analyse de cycle de vie sur
laquelle au moins l'un des indicateurs a
été amélioré vous pouvez prétendre que
votre produit a été éco-conçu et vous
pouvez choisir en gros n'importe lequel
de ces indicateurs avec une seule règle
c'est qu'il ne doit pas y avoir de ce
qu'on appelle le transfert de pollution
c'est-à-dire que ce qui aura été
amélioré d'un côté ne doit pas avoir un
préjudice négatif de l'autre par exemple
sur la cycle de vie de mon produit je
choisis d'améliorer mon procédé de
fabrication
et donc je diminue un certain nombre
d'indicateurs environnementaux si la
conséquence de ces améliorations là vont
se traduire par une dégradation de ma
face d'utilisation ben je vous régénérer
ce que je rappellerai un transfert de
pollution et je ne serai pas dans une
démarche d'écoconception donc on doit
améliorer un indicateur un ou plusieurs
indicateurs mais sans transfert de
pollution
donc la démarche des coûts se limite à
ça
alors
ça veut dire que en gros
à partir du moment où vous avez quelque
chose qui qui est d'impact amélioré
l'éco-conception on pourrait être mise
comme ayant été atteintes mais avec
quand même un certain nombre de limites
puisque comme je vous l'ai dit on va
s'appuyer sur un certain nombre
d'indicateurs environnementaux et c'est
un petit peu ce que disait madame
Gontard juste au préalable tout n'est
pas modélisé dans cette analyse de cycle
de vie il n'existe pas des indicateurs
environnementaux pour tous les impacts
environnementaux il y a plein de choses
qui aujourd'hui ne sont pas prises en
compte par l'Analyse de Cycle de Vie
l'impact toxicologique sur l'humain
l'impact sur la biodiversité l'empreinte
plastique dont on a déjà entendu parler
donc ça veut dire que en gros si on veut
aller très loin et bien clairement la CV
est un bon indicateur l'éco-conception
est à bande indicateur mais il n'est pas
toujours suffisant
alors
malgré tout est-ce que l'on peut quand
même relier l'utilisation de matière
plastique recyclée à une meilleure écho
conception alors si j'utilise de la
matière plastique recyclée ça veut dire
que en gros je vais me focaliser sur la
partie matériaux de mon analyse de cycle
de vie on va faire l'hypothèse que cette
utilisation de matière plastique
recyclée n'aura pas d'impact ni sur la
fabrication à la distribution sur aucune
des autres étapes de du cycle de vie
donc c'est sur la partie matériau brut
alors en toute rigueur si on veut
prétendre que l'utilisation de la
matière plastique recyclée contribue à
une meilleure éco-conception mais il
faut disposer de la modélisation
environnementale de la matière plastique
recyclée
c'est-à-dire qu'il faut disposer de la
de l'Analyse de Cycle de Vie de votre
propre matière plastique recyclée et
aujourd'hui c'est extrêmement compliqué
à atteindre et c'est extrêmement
compliqué à établir parce que les
données ne sont quasiment pas
disponibles on peut malgré tout faire
des hypothèses bien évidemment si on
considère que la matière plastique
recyclée permet d'éviter de consommer du
pétrole et bien il y a le facteur
consommation ressources épuisable qui va
être améliorée le RMD risque d'être
proche de zéro en revanche on sait que
quand on recycle une matière plastique
il y a des étapes de collecte il y a des
étapes de tri il y a des étapes de
lavage notamment et pour la vie de
matière plastique il faut par exemple
consommer de l'eau donc vous avez
forcément un facteur des PlayStation qui
va entrer en compte et qui aujourd'hui
n'est pas toujours correctement prise en
compte avec des centres de tri qui ne
sont pas forcément équipés de centrales
de de
récupération et de traitement des eaux
donc on aujourd'hui on est face à une
certaine forme
d'incertitude autour
de l'impact réel en termes d'accv d'une
matière plastique recyclée alors ça ne
veut pas dire que les impacts sont
négatifs je dis simplement
qu'aujourd'hui ça n'est pas documenté
c'est mal connu et c'est juste en train
d'être construit
alors ça c'est le premier élément le
deuxième élément c'est que fonction des
types de produits et bien le fait de
modifier quelque chose sur la phase
matériau n'aura pas forcément le même
impact je m'explique au travers de la
diapositive suivante et on va prendre un
exemple c'est un exemple de système
électrique donc c'est un système
c'est une prise électrique donc avec
l'ensemble des composants qui sont
constituent la prise électrique et si on
regarde l'analyse de cycle de vie d'un
système de ce type là ce sera la
diapositive suivante on voit que l'on
arrive à ce tableau de données alors
ce tableau de données
ce qu'il faut considérer et bien c'est
que quand on regarde par exemple le
premier indicateur qui est la
contribution réchauffement climatique et
bien on voit que en gros
c'est la partie utilisation qui pèse le
plus 77% de la contribution de ce
système là au réchauffement climatique
est porté par la phase d'utilisation et
vous pouvez voir que cette phase
d'utilisation et bien dans la plupart
des cas dans l'un pour la plupart des
indicateurs c'est elle qui pèse le plus
dans l'Analyse de Cycle de Vie global
alors la conséquence est assez direct ça
veut dire que en gros si vous fabriquez
cette prise avec une matière plastique
recyclée et que vous cherchez à
capitaliser l'utilisation de cette
matière plastique recyclée au travers de
l'Analyse de Cycle de Vie le résultat
sera maigre c'est à dire que la phase
d'utilisation étant la phase la plus
impactante mais en gros vous pouvez
faire tout ce que vous voulez en amont
il y aura pas de changement majoritaire
et très impactant alors ça ne veut pas
dire qu'il ne faut pas utiliser de
matière plastique recyclée pour
fabriquer une prise électrique ça veut
simplement dire que si l'on veut
valoriser l'utilisation de cette matière
plastique recyclée dans la prise
électrique et bien il faut choisir
d'autres vecteurs de consolidation et de
capitalisation que l'Analyse de Cycle de
Vie ou que l'éco-conception
et ça ce constat là il est valable
finalement pour tous les produits pour
lesquels la phase de vie et la phase la
plus impactante
alors est-ce que les coûts conception
permet de mieux recycler une matière
plastique d'un produit en fin de vie
donc dit autrement est-ce que on
choisissant correctement la manière dont
je vais concevoir mon produit est-ce que
je vais être susceptible de favoriser
un traitement optimal de sa fin de vie
avec idéalement des opérations de
recyclage facilité
alors très clairement ça va dépendre de
la durée de vie du produit
si vous êtes sur un produit avec une
durée de vie courte on peut se dire que
l'on va facilement pouvoir anticiper ce
qui va se passer dès la phase de
conception puisque finalement on se
projettera sur quelques semaines
quelques mois quelques années peut-être
et en gros vous allez assez facilement
pouvoir penser un produit pour vous dire
je vais faire en sorte que quand il va
arriver à l'état de fin de vie et bien
on puisse le recycler et le valoriser la
meilleure manière qui soit
c'est le cas le plus facile quand vous
êtes sur un produit avec une durée de
vie longue je parle
durée de vie de plusieurs dizaines
d'années là s'oppose à notre problème
très clairement une matière plastique
n'est pas un matériau inerte une matière
plastique est un matériau qui avec
l'effet du temps avec l'effet des
contraintes environnementales avec
l'effet des événements climatiques
divers et variés va avoir tendance à se
dégrader elle va vieillir donc avant
qu'elle ne devienne un microplastic elle
reste un objet compact mais qui aura
vécu et qui se rapporteur
de petites dégradations
et lorsque ce matériau là va arriver en
fin de vie et qu'il sera récupéré et
bien la dégradation dans la plupart des
cas sera tellement avancée que en gros
ça deviendra assez compliqué à recycler
mes
à cette dégradation là va
potentiellement s'ajouter des phénomènes
de contamination la matière peut être
souillée elle peut avoir rencontré des
événements des environnements agressifs
ou plutôt polluants donc être porteuse
d'huile des choses comme ça et donc tout
ça conduira finalement à ce que cette
matière là va soit difficile à recycler
et là vous pouvez envisager toutes les
modalités des cours conception que vous
voulez vous pouvez faire en sorte que la
le produit soit démantelable le plus
facilement possible que les choix
matériaux aient été faits de la manière
la plus judicieuse possible et bien à
cette étape après plusieurs dizaines
d'années d'utilisation et c'est le cas
en fait un des produits
électrotechniques et bien le matériau
sera partiellement dégradé
alors ça ne veut pas dire que tout est
perdu non ça veut tout simplement dire
que on doit bien avoir en tête que
l'ensemble des matières plastiques que
l'on consomme aujourd'hui n'ont pas été
pensées dans une logique de recyclage la
pétrochimie a développé plein de
solutions pour servir un certain nombre
de besoins mais jusqu'à il y a très peu
de temps personne n'a réellement pensé
recyclage dès la phase de conception ou
de fabrication ou de synthèse d'une
matière plastique recyclée
le hasard fait que il y en a certaines
qui s'avère être plus apte que d'autres
à des formes de recyclage chimiques on
peut parler de recyclage chimique avec
des polystyrènes des polémides des pets
des PVT avec des entités qui sont déjà
aujourd'hui en train d'utiliser ces
technologies là je peux citer Michelin
par exemple qui aujourd'hui est en train
de s'équiper d'unités de dépoliérisation
pour récupérer du sirène et réintégrer
ce styrène là dans des pneus on a des
unités ou en Italie qui sont aujourd'hui
capables de dépoliériser des polyamides
on a entendu parler autour de
Clermont-Ferrand également de structures
qui sont en train de se déployer pour
dépoliériser des pet par voie
enzymatiques donc on sent qu'il y a des
matériaux qui aujourd'hui sont aptes et
capables recyclage chimiques on sait
aussi qu'il y a d'autres matériaux qui
sont aussi en gestation et qui
probablement seront pensés pour être
recyclés chimiquement mais si on veut
aller vers ces approches là il pas
forcément des compromis acceptés
c'est-à-dire qu'il faudra peut-être
accepter des émissions environnementales
supplémentaires par rapport à la
valorisation des déchets parce que je le
rappelle l'exemple de l'arbre que cité
madame comptard est un système qui
fonctionne très bien tout simplement
parce que l'ensemble des entrants sont
des entrants gratuits l'arbre il
bénéficient de l'énergie du soleil et
c'est une énergie gratuite il bénéficie
de l'eau qui est une énergie gratuite et
en plus il est aidé par des multitudes
de travailleurs indépendants qui sont
dans le sous-sol qui sont des
micro-organismes et qui ne demandent pas
de salaire donc il faut simplement se
dire que si l'on veut reconstruire le
même mode de circularité basé sur
l'arbre et bien il faut simplement
accepter de payer la totalité de ce qui
va être en lien avec ces activités là et
risque donc de ce fait là de se poser un
problème de coût c'est à dire le coût de
ces solutions là à recycler chimiquement
et autres comparativement à celle des
solutions
issues des technologies
pétrochimiques classiques
voilà je vous remercie pour votre
attention et je reste à votre écoute
pour toute question éventuelle
je vous remercie monsieur Gabus et les
deux dernières interventions montrent
bien les différences de position et de
point de vue qui peut y avoir autour
d'un sujet qui est suit du recyclage
nous avons une dernière intervenante qui
va présenter ses idées c'est Madame
Valérie Guillard qui est professeur à
l'Université Paris Dauphine alors les
précédentes étapes du traité
international ont mis en évidence que la
lutte contre la pollution plastique
serait efficace que si nous arrivons à
réduire la production de polymère
plastique primaire cela signifie
concrètement une diminution drastique de
la consommation des plastiques à
l'échelle planétaire comment y parvenir
quelles sont les freins à lever
qu'est-ce que va nous expliquer madame
Guillard alors malheureusement madame
Guillard était retenue de longue date à
la date d'aujourd'hui donc ce qui
l'empêche d'être physiquement présente
avec nous aussi nous allons écouter une
contribution qui a été enregistrée avant
l'audition publique
monsieur le député madame la sénatrice
chers collègues je vous remercie de
votre invitation à parler de la
réduction de la consommation de
plastique je tiens tout d'abord à
m'excuser dans mon absence ne pouvant
pas déplacer un engagement à
l'université que j'ai ce jour en
préambule je précise que je parle du
prisme des sciences de gestion puisque
c'est un champ dans lequel je m'inscris
je le mobilise plus particulièrement par
l'angle du comportement du consommateur
et notamment l'analyse de ces pratiques
puisque c'est là que ce niche mon
expertise je vais vous présenter donc
une dizaine de minutes les difficultés
des consommateurs à réduire leur
consommation de plastique je parlerai
essentiellement en fait des plastiques
non ou peu réutilisables ceux qui crée
davantage de déchets et ce dans
essentiellement deux domaines
l'alimentaire et le textile donc
l'alimentaire je vais donner quelques
exemples plutôt sur les emballages
plastique à usage unique et puis au
niveau et donc de l'emballage d'ailleurs
alimentaire et au niveau du textile je
vais plutôt me focaliser bien entendu
sur la face fashion mais ce sont
vraiment deux domaines puisque voilà le
temps et contraint bien sûr il y a bien
évidemment bien d'autres domaines dans
lesquels on pourrait avoir ce type de
réflexion je vais structurer mon propos
en trois points mais finalement ces
points seront assez j'ai envie de dire
presque interconnecté les freins des
consommateurs à changer leurs habitudes
de consommation
l'offre des entreprises et bien entendu
le rôle des pouvoirs publics des
politiques publiques plus précisément et
notamment aussi le rôle des territoires
en effet je pense qu'une réduction de la
consommation de plastique passe par
l'interaction entre ces trois parties
prenantes de plus la prise en compte de
ces trois acteurs permet un partage de
responsabilité il faut savoir en fait
que que quand on interroge des
consommateurs et bien souvent dans les
discours on a oui mais il faut arrêter
nous culpabiliser il y a pas que nous
entre guillemets qui devons agir pour la
transition écologique et donc ils se
sentent un peu culpabilisés par les
discours sur les enjeux écologiques et
puis de toute façon d'une façon
extrêmement concrète c'est vraiment
l'interaction dans la vie sociale entre
évidemment organisation entreprise
envisations non marchande entreprise
consommateurs pouvoirs publics etc et
c'est vraiment toute cette écosystème
toute cette jambe bien cette analyse
systémique qui va nous permettre
évidemment d'avancer ensemble alors tout
d'abord quels sont finalement les fonds
à changer les modes de vie vers moins de
plastique de consommation plastique mais
en fait au lieu de vous présenter en
fait les raisons un peu de façon un peu
linéaire les raisons matérielles ou
logistiques sociales en rapport avec les
normes économique en rapport avec les
prix culturels en des habitudes
psychologiques en rapport avec la non
envie de faire des efforts et
d'envisager d'autres façons de faire
finalement toutes ces raisons je les ai
structurées en trois étapes
en trois étapes voilà qui vraiment qui
caractérise si vous voulez la façon de
consommer
le savoir le vouloir et le faire et dans
le faire finalement il y a surtout le
pouvoir faire donc toutes ces étapes
sont finalement je trouve des étapes en
vue de la transformation des modes de
vie alors tout d'abord pendant la
première étape le savoir la question qui
se pose en fait c'est est-ce que le
consommateur il sait qu'il consomme du
plastique question peut-être un peu
stupide mais qui je pense que c'est une
vraie question en fait et au-delà de ça
finalement est-ce que le consommateur il
a conscience qu'il consomme du plastique
et surtout de ce qui génère en
consommant du plastique je prends un
exemple parce que évidemment
l'information pas bien sûr la même chose
le même concept que la prise de
conscience
je vais prendre un exemple dans le
domaine donc du textile le consommateur
cette île que ces vêtements de fast
fashion contiennent du plastique il y a
un vrai travail quand même des marques
et aussi des organisations je pense
notamment à l'éthique sur l'étiquette
par exemple il y a un vrai travail sur
les étiquettes il y a une vraie travail
sur l'information parfois cette
information elle est pas vraiment
comprise voilà donc la question c'est
dire est-ce qu'il fait ce travail de
réflexivité est-ce que il sait des
conséquences que ça sur le vivant de
consommer certains vêtements entre
guillemets plastiques
et aussi est-ce que le consommateur sait
que l'usage de matière recyclée dans ses
vêtements n'est pas nécessairement
meilleur et plus écologique en effet en
fait j'imagine que Monsieur Gabus donc
avant moi la sans doute évoqué mais dans
la mode il y a un discours aujourd'hui
sur le recyclé
on vient certainement de mieux expliquer
au consommateurs
parce que ce qu'il faut faire alors
quand je dis il faut faire c'est
vraiment dans un dans une vision pour la
transition écologique pour un mode de
vie plus sobre et pour réduire les
conséquences de notre consommation sur
le vivant donc il faut faire c'est ce
que ça signifie c'est vraiment restreint
notre consommation aux besoins et ne pas
utiliser des détours par exemple la mode
avec du textile recyclé pour se donner
un bon argument et pour effectivement
j'ai envie de dire consommer des choses
continuent à consommer dans le même
rythme que précédemment donc en fait ça
pose une question notamment pour les
pouvoirs publics je pense c'est celle de
l'information du consommateur et une
information claire voir une orientation
pour j'ai envie de dire faire des
pratiques qui sont meilleures pour le
vivant et donc en termes écologique et
social donc ça c'est la première étape
c'est vraiment la question du savoir la
deuxième étape c'est le vouloir le
consommateur souhaite-il utiliser moins
de plastique alors
je pense que c'est vraiment une question
importante que la transformation des
modes de vie elle demande un effort elle
demande un effort cognitif donc
s'informer chercher à substituer le
plastique pardon de matière elle demande
un effort physique le plastique c'est
pratique
il est léger il donne confiance avec la
crise de la covid on a bien vu qu'on
avait une résurgence par exemple
d'emballage plastique et ça donnait
confiance aux consommateurs
qu'est-ce qui pourrait être alternatif à
effectivement le plastique si on prend
l'alimentaire faire des courses dans un
magasin de vrac il faut le dire c'est un
peu plus contraignant que dans un
magasin où disons le concrètement dans
une grande surface où effectivement il y
a plus de d'emballage plastique dans un
magasin de vrac on pense à apprendre
c'est ça qu'il faut c'est ça qu'on craft
si on veut être logique jusqu'au bout il
faut prendre c'est pour en verre donc en
fait il faut vraiment il y a une
logistique à repenser et là la question
c'est de savoir est-ce que le
consommateur est prêt à repenser sa
logistique
qu'est-ce que et surtout qu'est-ce
comment on fait les organisations donc
les entreprises les grandes surfaces
peuvent l'accompagner dans ce changement
pour pas qu'il soit justement tout seul
et qu'il en perçoivent tous les coups
est-ce que si on prend la grande surface
par exemple et on sait que surface il y
a beaucoup de suremballage que fait la
grande surface pour aider la grande
distribution pardon pour aider les
consommateurs à l'encourager à prendre
ses propres contenants tout cela semble
assez finalement évident mais quand on
est dans ce type de lieu de distribution
on voit bien que la grande surface ne
fait pas énormément d'efforts pour
effectivement faciliter en fait
l'initiative de consommateur à venir
avec ses contenus donc en fait est-ce
que d'ailleurs la grande surface doit
même valoriser ce type de de
comportement avec une gratification par
exemple c'est pas une gratification sur
la carte de fidélité ou je ne sais quel
outil de bien marketing donc en fait le
consommateur aujourd'hui il est dans un
quand même dans un certain confort dans
une certaine habitude changer il faut
toujours se dire que changer n'est pas
sa priorité au quotidien parce que ça
demande du temps ça demande une vraie
réflexion donc comme je vous l'ai dit ça
dans des efforts ça demande une
réflexion aussi j'aime bien sur sur la
valeur temps est-ce qu'on prend le temps
de repenser son mode de vie pour moins
de plastique et donc pour d'autres
formes alternatives de consommation donc
je pense qu'il faut que ce soit facile
il faut que ça soit proposé il faut que
ça soit un véritable accompagnement par
notamment les entreprises puisqu'encore
une fois le consommateur seul ne pourra
pas entre guillemets changer et tout
faire et parvenir en fait à changer ses
modes de consommation
dernière étape j'ai envie de dire il y a
le pouvoir faire et le pouvoir faire en
fait la question c'est le consommateur
peut-il changer son mode de vie pour
moins de plastique alors effectivement
là ça pose la question des raisons
matérielles et économiques alors déjà
parfois il y a une absence de dispositif
qui rendent possible
autrement dit qui rendent possible le
changement de consommation par exemple
aujourd'hui je pense un exemple très
trivial mais si on ne veut plus utiliser
un style en plastique alors bien sûr
mais non il y a de plus en plus d'offres
de stylos qui ne sont pas en plastique
mais il y en a pas non plus enfin
spontanément c'est pas encore facile de
trouver la bonne marque et le voilà le
bon produit
aujourd'hui en fait la solution je vous
l'ai dit enfin c'était une solution
possible la solution alternative au
plastique on a parlé du vrac le vrac
reste cher le wrap reste coûteux parce
que soit vous avez du vrac qui est bio
soit vous avez du vrac qui est vendu
donc par exemple
magasin de centre-ville et on peut
légitimement penser que de par la
question des loyers et bien il y a une
répercussion sur le prix des produits et
les plus chers en effet qu'un produit
qui n'est pas vendu en vrac donc déjà le
consommateur a beaucoup de difficultés à
comprendre déjà cette différence de prix
alors bien sûr vous trouvez du vrac sur
les marchés etc ou qui sont quand même
moins coûteux mais si on veut orienter
ces consommations et notamment même
réattirer le consommateur dans le
centre-ville enfin voilà repenser
effectivement cette façon sa logistique
et sa façon de faire de les courses
alimentaires et bien voilà il est peu
encouragé de par des prix souvent plus
chers donc en fait il y a une et c'est
vrai aussi dans le domaine du textile
dans le domaine du textile effectivement
on a parlé de face fashion mais
effectivement le fast fashion évidemment
on sait que elle est beaucoup moins
coûteuse qu'un vêtement de mode plus
éthique plus durable
on sait qu'un sort de Fat fashion c'est
6 euros et un t-shirt de mode durable ça
peut être 18 et 20 euros donc voilà
toutes ces questions posent toute la
question sous-jacente qui est posée
c'est celle de la justice sociale et
voilà et comment effectivement permettre
aux différentes catégories sociales un
accès autre que un accès avec des
alternatives un accès pardon aux
alternatives qui utilisent moins de
plastique et qui sont beaucoup plus
coûteuses beaucoup plus cher pour le
consommateur donc ça je pense qu'il y a
une vraie question ici
ça pose une vraie question encore une
fois de justice sociale voir parfois
même presque de démocratisation par
exemple du vrac ça pose une question du
territoire est-ce que le territoire
encourage certaines initiatives je pense
notamment une initiative qui s'appelle
la tournée qui est dans la région
parisienne et qui permet aux
consommateurs par exemple d'avoir des
courses livrées et des en fait avec des
contenants en verre c'est pas du tout
j'imagine la seule initiative on va
voilà comment valoriser ce type
d'initiative qui va vraiment dans le
sens de la diminution des plastiques et
comment valoriser en fait ces
initiatives tu parles les territoires
par exemple voilà donc je vais
effectivement peut-être conclure cette
que j'arrive au bout du temps un parti
cette petite présentation donc je pense
vraiment qu'une diminution drastique de
notre consommation de plastique passe
par un accompagnement du consommateur en
termes d'information notamment et je
pense vraiment que c'est une question
qui est systémique c'est-à-dire qui est
questionne certes le consommateur ça
remise en cause effectivement de ces
modes de vie mais aussi l'offre des
entreprises comment les entreprises
elles peuvent qu'elles offrent et à quel
prix elles peuvent proposer des
alternatives ça pose bien sûr la
question aussi pour les pouvoirs publics
certainement en termes d'information
voire un peu en termes d'orientation
parce que une fois le consommateur il
est un peu perdu il aimerait pour
certaines catégories évidemment j'en
garde mieux consommer mais je pense
qu'il faut parfois lui indiquer quel
chemin prendre pour mieux consommer et
puis bien sûr ça pose aussi la question
de la valorisation par les territoires
comment les territoires peuvent t'aider
la mise en place de ces pratiques
alternatives bien évidemment je reste à
vos dispositions pour des questions
complémentaires sur ces changements de
mode de vie et par plus particulièrement
sur les plastiques n'hésitez pas à me
faire parvenir vos questions je serai
vraiment ravie de d'y répondre voilà et
bien écoutez je vous remercie de votre
attention je vous remercie effectivement
de votre invitation à parler assez
rapidement effectivement de ces
changements de mode de vie pour des
modes de vie plus sobre en plastique et
encore une fois je répète je reste à
votre dispositions pour voilà davantage
de questions par mail ou autre pour
répondre à votre question voilà merci et
très bonne journée
je vous remercie madame Guillard pour
cette présentation de cette dimension
qui est souvent oubliée mais qui est
essentielle cette dimension sociale et
de justice enfin une société elle est de
justice sociale et qui est de mon point
de vue particulièrement important
surtout lorsque ça intéresse à un traité
international sur la pollution plastique
on sait que les niveaux de vie sont dans
les niveaux de développement économique
des différents pays sont loin d'être
comparables entre eux et c'est surtout
important de le présenter en mettant en
évidence
c'est-à-dire en corrélant ce rôle
important de la dimension sociale dans
le corrélan ou au rôle essentiel du
monde économique et de celui des
pouvoirs publics si vous ne permettez
monsieur le Président je voudrais poser
quelques questions à certaines nous
intervenants je vais les prendre dans
l'ordre monsieur Chali en premier lieu
vous nous avez parlé du positionnement
d'un certain nombre de pays et j'ai
alors sauf erreur de ma part j'ai pas
entendu quelle serait la position dans
les négociations actuelles d'un grand
pays qui est la Chine et des évolutions
de du dans le positionnement par rapport
au traité d'autres pays qui sont devenus
aujourd'hui les destinataires de de
déchets plastiques justement suite à la
fermeture des des frontières chinoises
et d'autres pays asiatiques voilà pour
pour vous j'ai peut-être posé toutes les
questions et puis chacun pourrait y
répondre dans l'ordre ensuite une
question pour madame
Guérard oui
qu'en est-il des réglementations
ailleurs dans le monde on a vu vous nous
avez fait une démonstration de ce qui
existe en Europe qu'en est-il ailleurs
et les fringues que vous avez démontré
dans les réglementations enfin les
limites que vous avez démontées dans la
réglementation européenne avec donc en
fonction de ce qui existe d'ailleurs
d'aventuelles incohérence est-ce que
tout cela n'est pas finalement une sorte
de talon d'Achille dans le traité
international des possibilités justement
de ne pas aller aussi loin que que l'on
voudrait quoi ensuite j'ai une question
pour Madame Gontard
alors donc la vision nationale et
européenne vous l'avez bien mis en
évidence du de l'écho de l'économie
circulaire elle est très centrée sur le
sur le recyclage en oubliant d'autres
dimensions c'est les trois heures quand
même l'économie circulaire et c'est les
autres r C'est la réduction leur emploi
la réutilisation ou la réparation voilà
donc ça c'est c'est important de le
signaler mais alors que va-t-il se
passer maintenant je reviens aussi sur
la dimension internationale de notre
traité on sait que tous les pays n'en
vont pas avoir cette même capacité à
investir des moyens importants dans le
dans le recyclage et pour autant
certains sont destinataires de quantités
importantes de déchets donc que vont-ils
en faire et finalement est-ce que faut
pas lire dans ce cas une sorte de de
notre d'espoir où finalement ceux qui
auraient des déchets à gérer importants
mais pas les capacités à développer des
infrastructures de recyclage deviendrait
les promoteurs de des autres r que je
viens de citer ceux du de la réduction
du réemploi de la réutilisation et de la
réparation
et puis dernière question pour Monsieur
Gabus
donc vous nous avez présenté la CV
au-delà de l'exemple que nous avait
présenté vous nous avez bien mis en
évidence les complexités d'analyse de
cycle de vie et je voudrais savoir parce
que je me positionne toujours dans cette
perspective du traité international a
bien vouloir faire donc on a vu qu'il y
avait une limite déjà ce qui avait pas
la dans la CV il y avait pas les
microplastiques et donc d'autres impacts
des plastiques au-delà du carbone mais
si on voulait vraiment rendre une ACV
puissante au niveau international il
faudrait donc qu'elle puisse il y a une
notion d'échelle géographique et il
faudrait qu'au-delà de l'échelle de ce
que du produit qu'on qu'on soit pour le
marché et sans le territoire de ce
marché là il faudrait aussi qu'on soit
en capacité d'avoir des ACV qui nous
indiquent quels sont les impacts que ça
peut avoir dans d'autres pays plus
lointains éviter qu'ils soient négatif
voilà je sais c'est plus une remarque
d'ailleurs qu'une qu'une question à ce
propos là quoi merci à vous
qui veut commencer alors est-ce qu'on a
toujours monsieur Chali avec nous
d'accord ok les yeux
merci
[Musique]
j'ai l'impression de pas là la
Commission européenne je me permets un
peu de représenter de ce que la Chine où
est-ce que se trouve la Chine et on sait
déjà que depuis la l'adoption de la loi
qui s'appelle la loi de la PP national
de la Chine il a eu une interaction de
l'importation des dossiers plastiques en
Chine ils savent bouleversé le monde et
on sait que c'est une politique
nationale que
a accéléré
les questionnements et aussi les
démarches à niveau régional au niveau
internationaux et grâce à ça on a obtenu
au moins de 1 an en amendement de la
Convention des valves sous les contrôles
de déchets donc ça c'est une première
chose à remarquer on s'est déjà aussi
que la Chine a aussi envoyé une
contribution pour la deuxième rang de
négociation en
qui s'éteindra à Paris et dans cet ordre
d'idée et là envoyer un brouillon des
objectifs pour les traiter que c'est
assez particulier parce qu'il prend deux
dimensions tout d'abord c'est une
dimension des protéger
les ceintures liés à l'environnement il
adoptieme c'est la dimension de la santé
humaine donc ça on voit une avancée par
rapport à ces discussions là après
elle part des à niveau des objectifs ou
des mesures contraignantes promouvoir la
production et la consommation
durable du plastique et mais quand il
s'agit des mesures plus concrètes elles
pensent à des mesures volontaires au
niveau des restrictions des plastiques
des additifs des produits qui certains
applications de plastique mais déjà on
voit une évolution si on voit deux trois
jours on avance la Chine ne voulait pas
parler de des
prévisions des restrictions donc on voit
déjà que dans les débats il est prêt à
la discussion donc j'aimerais être là
même merci pour la question
je vous en prie prenez la parole pour le
donc je n'ai pas beaucoup d'éléments de
réponse à votre question qui est
vraiment très intéressant je sais qu'il
y a le système REACH est vraiment tout à
fait unique au monde puisqu'il y a
vraiment fournit une base de données
très importante sur les sur les produits
chimiques et les risques associés alors
au niveau de la sécurité qui est
particulière qui concerne la sécurité
des aliments la présence de substances
chimiques dans les aliments on a
d'autres systèmes équivalents à vivre ça
comme la FTA et au niveau des tous les
pays c'est que le CDE offre vraiment
pour aider les pays justement à mettre
en place en fait à élaborer vraiment des
stratégies pour
réduire les risques liés à l'exposition
produits chimiques mais je suis désolé
de ne pas avoir plus d'éléments
oui question ah c'est bon tout va bien
question sur les
sur les la dimension internationale je
suis pas sûr d'avoir bien compris en
fait niveau question ni peut-être le
raisonnement qui a derrière je vous la
formule vous nous avez mis en évidence
le fait qu'ici on avait un centré de
notre approche de l'économie circulaire
autour du recyclage ok on a la
perspective d'un traité international
qui s'ouvre devant nous et le sujet du
recyclage est évidemment sur la table
tous les pays ne pourront pas disposer
de l'infrastructure qui est la nôtre en
matière de geste de tri de collecte de
tri puis de recyclage
et certaines de ces produits ces pays-là
reçoivent d'autant plus des quantités de
plastique donc est-ce que ça va pas être
finalement pour eux l'occasion de
réaffirmer qu'au-delà du recyclage il y
a d'autres r dans l'économie circulaire
qui sont ceux de la réduction ça
éviterait d'avoir des déchets qui
arrivent chez eux du réemploi de la
réparation de la réutilisation etc oui
peut-être qu'on va pouvoir faire la
démonstration alors bon déjà au niveau
des r sur le réemploi c'est c'est très
difficile pour le plastique il a pas été
conçu non plus pour ça il peut être
employé mais de façon très limitée c'est
pas du vert le vert est un matériau
densinerte le plastique c'est pas du
tout le cas donc là aussi miser sur le
réemploi pour réduire significativement
la pollution plastique que je pense que
non c'est pas enfin c'est pas
raisonnable quoi c'est pas c'est pas un
matériau qui est fait pour ça donc dans
les dans les trois heures justement
bon voilà on est dans le premier
actuellement
il y a alors la dimension internationale
le problème c'est que nos déchets
voyages et puis nos déchets voyagent
aussi par la mer c'est-à-dire très
souvent ce pays-là
lorsqu'on a par exemple des déchets qui
franchissent tout un tas de frontières
et qui se retrouvent au fin fond de la
Chine bah finalement ils finissent se
jeter dans les océans ou brûler ou
enfouis alors on a cette problématique
qui se pose énormément pour les îles
pour les étincellaires parce que eux se
retrouvent à devoir gérer des déchets
qui ne savent même pas d'où ils viennent
c'est-à-dire ou alors ils voient qu'ils
viennent de très très loin et donc se
retrouve là avec la problématique ça
sert à quoi de réduire leurs déchets
puisque de toute façon ce ne sont pas
les leurs et pour beaucoup de pays c'est
le cas sauf que ce qu'on appelle
recyclage comme je vous l'ai expliqué
c'est du des cyclage c'est à dire qu'en
gros on met en place des filières
entières pour tapisser le pays de tous
ces déchets plastiques donc on sait pas
quoi faire ou on va les stocker sous
forme de tout un tas d'objets qui vont
paraître comme écologique et vertueux
alors qu'ils ne le sont pas alors nous
bien entendu alors chez eux évidemment
la réduction elle est elle est encore
plus importante mais je le répète encore
une fois la production la consommation
de plastique est parfaitement corrélée
au PIB donc nous sommes parmi les pays
les plus consommateurs de plastique les
seuls pays qui décrochent justement ce
sont les décroches ce sont les les pays
du Golfe parce qu'ils ont des revenus
tellement élevés que de toute façon la
consommation de plastique ne suit pas
derrière mais vraiment c'est
parfaitement corrélé donc ça veut dire
qu'un pays qui pas les moyens c'est de
traiter des déchets plastiques c'est
aussi un pays qui en consomme beaucoup
moins après il y a il y a par exemple la
Convention de Bâle qui régit les
mouvements transfrontaliers des déchets
dangereux et le plastique en fait partie
en fait sauf que à partir du moment où
le pays peut démontrer qu'il est capable
d'appliquer une gestion écologiquement
responsable de ce déchet et bien le
déchet n'est plus dangereux et pour le
plastique c'est très simple il suffit de
collecter de trier et de déceler donc
infini le plastique passe au travers de
la convention de balles complètement
voilà parce que on demande et moi je
vois pour être engagé dans pas mal de
projets qui qui sont actifs autour de ce
problème de comment on gère la pollution
plastique dans les pays du Sud et ben
actuellement
à part le des cyclages il y a pas
beaucoup d'autres
solution et d'autres supports sachant
que la réduction elle a un impact est
limité dans la mesure où pour beaucoup
des déchets qu'ils ont à gérer c'est des
déchets qui ne viennent qui ne sont pas
les leurs donc ça pose quand même un
problème et là je pense qu'il faut qu'on
il faut vraiment qu'on prenne nos
responsabilités moi ça c'est quelque
chose qui me paraît vraiment très très
important
il faut vraiment qu'on regarde les
choses en face et qu'on et qu'on
interdise ces mouvements
transfrontaliers de plastique les
déchets plastiques que nous produisons
nous devons les gérer nous-mêmes et ne
cherchons pas à les aider des pays
allégé puisque nous-mêmes je le répète
encore nous ne savons pas les gérer
correctement
merci Philippe et justement je vais
rebondir sur ce sujet en parlant de de
la pollution qui est due à l'usage du
plastique qu'on fait dans les textiles
nous avons ces dernières années
multipliées en France par deux notre 15
ans notre consommation de textile et qui
sont majoritairement fait à base de
plastique et je rejoins ce qui a été dit
dans la dernière intervention à savoir
que certainement que les citoyens enfin
les consommateurs ne savent pas que
leurs vêtements sont en plastique et que
donc ça pose un problème cette
surconsommation parce qu'il y a très
concrètement une surconsommation de
vêtements ces dernières années en
plastique et justement je voudrais
mettre le focus sur une matière qu'on
avait étudié déjà dans notre rapport qui
s'appelle le tissu polaire
qui est un matériau textile qui résulte
des cyclages comme ça a été dit qui va
relarguer dans l'environnement des
quantités phénoménales de microfibres et
justement peut-être de demander à
Monsieur onkeux sur le bilan qu'il fait
de l'arrivée dans l'environnement s'il y
a s'il y aura un sujet sur ces
microfibres parce qu'on va les retrouver
dans l'air également parce que c'est
tellement léger qui pourront poser
éventuellement d'autres problèmes de
santé comment on les documents dans
l'air et puis après qu'on les retrouve
partout au sommet des de l'Everest par
exemple dans dans les grands fonds
marins partout on va retrouver ces
microfibres textiles et est-ce que ça ne
va pas poser un problème particulier de
par leur forme de par la façon dont
elles pourront être ingérées par
même des organismes comme des vers de
terre et sur le sujet que on a
contrairement à pas mal d'autres
matériaux en plastique pour ce tissu là
une arrivée dans l'environnement qui est
phénoménale et je rejoins ce qui est ce
que ce qu'a dit Madame Gontard tout à
l'heure à propos des machines à laver
sur les filtres qui
hypothétiquement enfin on ne sait pas
potentiellement serait capable de moi
j'ai des gros doutes là dessus et en
plus qu'on a mis la charge sur les
fabricants de machine à laver et pas
pour ceux qui sont à l'origine de la
mise dans l'environnement de ces
micro-fibres donc voilà ce sujet et le
sujet du fait que les consommateurs ne
savent pas moi j'avais fait voter dans
la loi climat et résilience au Sénat un
amendement qui obligeait à les metteurs
en marché de ces produits textiles à
inscrire qu'il relargue dans
l'environnement des microfibres tout au
long de leur cycle de vie et je pense
que pour le traité international il
faudra certainement intégrer cette
nouveauté en fait de du de l'arrivée
dans l'environnement de façon très
massive de ces microfibres qui va poser
peut-être d'autres problèmes que ceux
qu'on a envisagé jusqu'à présent donc
voilà Monsieur Zonko éventuellement si
vous avez une réponse et je ne sais pas
si d'autres personnes par rapport au
traité veulent intervenir sur ce sujet
de l'arrivée massive dans
l'environnement des microfibres textiles
et je voudrais bien dire que la remarque
de danger de prévu de ma collègue est
particulièrement pertinente parce qu'il
y a une autre façon de lire le sujet du
textile dans la perspective du traité
c'est qu'on sait très bien aujourd'hui
que les filières d'exportation des
déchets textiles chez nous c'est surtout
l'exploitation et donc des pays qui vont
recevoir tous ces tissu là et je rajoute
que nous envoyons vous savez qu'on fait
le tri on commence à instaurer ça
maintenant en France le tri des textiles
et qu'on envoie énormément de vêtements
en fait en Afrique et que sous couvert
humanitaire qu'évidemment là-bas
avec cette nouveauté des de ces textiles
en plastique mais les Africaines disent
très concrètement qu'elles ne peuvent
rien en faire et que c'est en train de
s'accumuler et je rejoins ce que vous
avez dit à propos de notre
responsabilité parce que là pour le coup
ça passe ou les radars c'est des envois
de vêtements mais qui finalement
finissent par du stockage un petit peu
partout sur les plages ou dans sur des
terrains en Afrique et très concrètement
nous nous savons pas non plus recycler
ses vêtements nous n'avons même pas
encore envisagé très concrètement de le
faire donc voilà on a une responsabilité
aussi à ce niveau là
merci Madame prévu pour pour ces
multiples questions je vais essayer de
répondre partiellement
les fibres vous avez aujourd'hui dans
l'atmosphère généralement c'est en
milieu urbain ou elles ont une taille
une longueur de 200 à 2000 micromètres
c'est-à-dire de 0,2 à 2 mm c'est
relativement
large observable parfois à l'ail nu je
soupçonne par exemple que les
microfibres observés au mont Everest
simplement la pollution locale des
milliers d'alpinistes qui qui
montent le mont Everest chaque année
les mesures de toute microplastiques et
microfibres dans l'environnement c'est
extrêmement difficile finalement on
passe des années au labo a peaufiner ses
analyses on a très vite des problèmes de
contamination de nos échantillons de par
nos vêtements qui sont faits en fibres
n'est ce pas donc les micro prendre
l'atmosphère je pense il y en a un
milieu urbain elles vont pas voyager
très loin on peut pas parler de
transport Intercontinental des
microfibres
comme on peut pour vraiment les
microparticules les plus fines au Pic du
Midi par exemple les microplastiques les
plus fines entre 3 et 10 on va dire
entre 3 et 20 micromètres c'est là son
subissent le transport Intercontinental
peuvent être émis par les océans et
c'est vraiment les plus petites donc je
pense aussi bien que je suis par
expérience les microfibres plus longs ne
vont pas non plus pénètre dans nos
poumons on les respire pas parce
qu'elles sont trop larges pour pour
pénétrer les particules les plus fines
jusqu'à 10 micromètres font partie des
fameuses P indice qui peuvent pénétrer
dans nos poumons
donc en termes de exposition de l'homme
[Musique]
c'est pas la plus grande préoccupation
peut-être mais peut-être les collègues
toxicologues peuvent
apporter des éléments aussi
les aspects impacts et effets mais juste
pour dire quand même qu'il y a pas mal
de pays africains qui se sont élevés
contre justement
ces arrivées massives de vêtements
usagés en fibres synthétique qui qui
portait atteinte au à leur marché à
leurs produits locaux et notamment le
coton alors parmi tous ces pays-là parce
qu'il y en a eu pas mal il y a eu
notamment donc Ronda Tanzanie Ouganda
Kenya etc il y a eu notamment le Rwanda
qui a qui avait commencé à interdire
l'arrivée de tous ces textiles des USA
il y a eu ensuite une bataille assez
importante avec une menace de
représailles commerciales vis-à-vis du
Rwanda sur ces pays locaux et du coup
ils ont ils ont été obligé de reprendre
de réaccepter à nouveau ces déchets pour
ne pas pouvoir en souffrir ensuite au
niveau économique voilà donc ça c'est
pour ça c'est une chose qui est
importante c'est à dire qu'il y a pas
mal de pays africains qui se sont qui se
sont élevés contre
de ces pratiques là et ensuite aussi que
les fibres synthétiques et c'est pas
seulement les textiles mais c'est aussi
la construction il faut quand même le
savoir et que par exemple parmi les
premières publications mais c'est pas
très vieux ça juste quelques années qui
ont analysé les les
particules plastiques étaient retrouvés
dans les glaces de l'Arctique et qui ont
essayé de tracer leur origine la
première origine semblerait être l'usure
des de certains matériaux utilisés dans
les bâtiments
l'usure de matériaux inter à l'intérieur
mais aussi à l'extérieur avec tout ce
qui est revêtement de protection
juste en se rappelant quand même que
actuellement une maison écologique bien
isolée et fourré de plastique de la tête
aux pieds
est-ce que je peux juste refaire voilà
par rapport à l'inhalation et par
rapport à justement aux conséquences que
ça peut avoir d'un point de vue
toxicologique donc en fait ce que je
peux que je peux vous apporter
aujourd'hui comme éclairage c'est qu'il
y avait une étude en 2019 au niveau
d'une étude d'une
équipe canadienne qui montrait que ils
avaient comparé en fait le nombre de
microplastiques qui étaient consommés
donc par l'alimentation par rapport au
nombre de microplastiques qui pouvaient
être inhalés et les niveaux étaient
relativement équivalents
voilà donc ça c'était une étude enfin
j'ai celle là en tête après j'ai pas
forcément en tête d'autres travaux parce
que moi je travaille plus sur le voilà
sur l'écosystème intestinal mais il faut
savoir voilà que au niveau pulmonaire
mais il y a des barrières il y a il y a
un épithélium pulmonaire il y a du mucus
qui peut aussi jouer un rôle de
protection il y a un microbiote
pulmonaire voilà donc peut-être par
rapport à tout ce que je vous ai tout ce
que je vous ai présenté aujourd'hui sur
l'écosystème intestinal il y a aussi des
travaux qui peuvent être menés alors
c'est vrai qu'il y a souvent un décalage
entre l'écosystème intestinal écosystème
pulmonaire les collègues qui travaillent
sur le poumon ils sont peut-être un peu
moins avancés sur cette thématique là
des microplastiques mais c'est vrai que
par rapport à ces enjeux de voilà de de
captation de franchissement de barrière
de translocation éventuelle pour les
plus petites particules moi je suis
d'accord enfin voilà c'est c'est quand
même voilà plutôt sur des petites
particules mais il faut aussi avoir la
métrologie pour les détecter ces petites
fractions il y a aussi peut-être voilà
des conséquences en termes de particules
inhalées et par rapport aux
communications des organes comme je vous
ai dit entre voilà intestins et poumons
il y a aussi peut-être des choses qui
peuvent se passer à ce niveau là
beaucoup j'avais autre chose aussi à
évoquer mais bon la dernière personne
n'est plus n'est pas en communication
avec nous donc on peut pas le lui
demander sur le savoir et le savoir le
vouloir et le faire des consommateurs
je sais bon peut-être demander
un peu tout le monde parce que moi il me
semble c'est vrai comment faire des
choix par rapport au vrac ou aux
emballages à quel moment je c'est une
question que je pose comme ça
l'emballage plastique deviendra
impossible pour le consommateur parce
qu'il saura tous les effets et comment
faire pour enfin pour introduire la
notion complète de ce qu'est de ce que
représente l'utilisation l'usage de
cette emballage plastique une barquette
de jambon par exemple par rapport à du
jambon à la découpe donc deviendrai je
rappelle que dans la loi on l'a mis on
peut venir avec son propre contenant
pour se faire servir à la découpe en
France c'est autorisé c'est même voilà
il y a pas de publicité qui est faite là
dessus mais on l'a mis dans la loi et
c'est applicable depuis le 1er janvier
l'année dernière comment faire pour que
le consommateur soit je dirais j'ai pas
d'autres mots soit écœuré en quelque
sorte d'avoir recours à la barquette de
jambon en plastique et ils se disent
c'est pas possible que j'utilise ça je
vais venir avec et c'est tout l'enjeu
c'est dommage qu'on n'est pas qu'on
puisse pas discuter avec elle parce que
sur les mécanismes qui font que le
consommateur serait dans mais sans avoir
besoin de ce de ce contraindre en aucune
manière mais qui n'aurait pas du tout
envie d'avoir recours donc il faudra
voilà expliciter tout ce que représente
l'image réelle de ce qu'est la pollution
plastique pour que chacun ait en tête
sans avoir besoin de faire des efforts
mais se dire ça non je
risque pas d'utiliser ça parce que voilà
c'est une question que j'ai comme ça
peut-être un élément de réflexion sur
ces plastiques je crois qu'en termes de
communication le plus difficile et de
communiquer lorsqu'on lorsqu'on explique
l'impact des plastiques on a bien
conscience que ça se passe longtemps
après notre utilisation et que et que je
crois que c'est aussi sur ce point-là
qu'il faudrait faire un effort de
communication sur ces sur ces aspects
bombards retardement et réservoir c'est
à dire que
là on est toujours en train de se dire
bah finalement on mange l'équivalent
d'une carte de bleu ou l'équivalent d'un
petit grain de riz de plastique on s'en
fout mais quelque part nous on parle
mais nous on n'a pas d'effet là
actuellement et et le plus difficile
c'est d'arriver à dire mais comment
pouvons-nous imaginer qu'il n'y ait pas
d'effet vu les quantités de plastique
qu'on a accumulé dans notre
environnement et qui sont en train de se
dégrader et je crois que c'est là où
réside la plus grande difficulté en
termes de communication et puis une
autre chose aussi que je voudrais dire
c'est qu'on parle beaucoup de
consommateurs moi j'aimerais que on
parle un petit peu plus aussi des
acteurs très très actifs que sont les
industriels comment les sensibilise
comment on leur donne envie comment et
je pense que c'est avec eux que le gros
du travail devrait aussi se faire et que
sans eux on peut rien faire c'est pas la
peine
merci peut-être que pour être bref ça
relié à une question qui a fait sur les
précédents en début des
alternatives que un éventaire national
une taxe de la conférence de nation unis
sur les commerces parlent de
remplacement il est divisions très
substituts et alternatif il a fait une
liste des codes douaniers on dit sans
qu'il y a plus de 300 remplacements déjà
là avec des avec des barrières au niveau
de commerce parce que les taux douaniers
sont plus élevés parfois que les mêmes
produits plastiques donc c'est un
rapport qui était qui était présenté la
semaine dernière et ça c'est intéressant
à savoir pour parce que il est un
travail qui commence à avancer par
rapport à cela
et on sait que dans les traité
internationale il y aura cette question
de remplacement mais aussi par rapport à
la matière plastique de transparence
c'est qui qui de recevoir quoi tout
d'abord c'est pas si un consommateur
très intéressant par les filtres UV 320
28 mais est-ce que c'est l'autorité
publique c'est le utilisateur en tant
que dans la chaîne de
d'approvisionnement c'est-à-dire la pas
les producteurs de la
précurseur mais c'est qu'il utilise qui
doit savoir qu'est-ce qui a beaucoup
beaucoup d'entreprises ne connaît pas
même pas qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'il y
a dans le matériel qui s'utilise mais il
y a des sectes déjà au niveau automoteur
des voitures qui commencent à se mettre
d'accord pour avoir des bases de données
de tous les matériels il est polymère
que ceux utilisent dans la production
des voitures et les pets l'exemple des
bouteilles pète c'est un exemple qui on
parle beaucoup de ça mais c'est parfois
les seuls exemples qu'on a entre
guillemets des réussites il s'était
parce que
ce met d'accord le centre industriels
pour avoir un certain degrés des
transparence donc là ça sera bien de
différencier savoir qu'est-ce que j'ai
commun ique c'est là qu'on parle
je voyais les verres là qui dit
recyclables là mais c'est cette partie
de leyble qu'il faudra faire attention
plutôt avec les consommateurs mais avec
l'utilisateur
cette idée de consolidation des données
de qu'est-ce qui sera possiblement
utilisable avec une liste positive merci
alors on va tranquillement se diriger
vers la fin de cette de cette audition
publique et en profiter pour vous
remercier toutes et tous et
particulièrement ceux qui ont participé
en direct en visio ou en présentiel à
cette seconde table ronde vous dire que
vous avez adressé un certain nombre de
messages essentiels et que c'est son
très importants cette notion de flux et
de stock ce stock qui est important donc
des images nous révèlent l'ampleur de la
pollution plastique et ce flux qui
continue à se poursuivre venant
alimenter un stock déjà important donc
il faut qu'on agisse là dessus on a bien
compris vous avez bien mis en évidence
les choses la prise de conscience je
pense est désormais réelle et des
leviers pour réduire ce flux existant
son nombreux et son globaux ce qui
marque aussi c'est que finalement
certaines objets plastiques produits à
un endroit de la planète peuvent faire
de la pollution ailleurs votre la
pollution globale donc c'est pour ça
qu'on attend beaucoup de ce traité
international et je voudrais terminer en
remerciant notre président d'avoir
accepté que l'Office parlementaire
d'évaluation des choses scientifiques et
techniques s'emparent de ce sujet là ce
qui montre que les les parlements
français sont attentifs à ce traité
international et que ça nous permettra
de faire une contribution au travers des
résultats et de la synthèse de la Table
Ronde merci monsieur le président
merci à tous nos intervenants pour
votre contribution adressée cette image
plus réelle de ce qu'est la pollution
plastique je vais pas être plus longue
merci chaleureusement vraiment pour vous
être déplacé et puis avoir permis
des éclairages encore supplémentaires à
nos connaissances merci encore
merci à vous bien écoutez merci à vous
également et on va pouvoir clore cette
séance et encore une fois
on voit bien tous les enjeux et tous les
intérêts que nous avons au sein de
l'office par l'auteur de l'action des
choix scientifiques et technologiques de
faire rentrer continuer à faire rentrer
la science au sein des décisions
politiques
notamment sur cet enjeu majeur donc on
compte sur vous comme on compte sur
l'ensemble des parlementaires mobilisés
au sein de l'office pour poursuivre ce
combat que ce soit au niveau
international comme au niveau national
et partout où champs le permettra merci
à tous
[Musique]